I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
虽然现在才年初，但我们已经在讨论暑假的家庭旅行了。你知道我们喜欢用Airbnb。我知道。嗯，我们喜欢有个厨房，而且我喜欢早上穿着睡袍走出来喝杯茶，就像你说的，珍娜，我喜欢那种自由自在的感觉。没错。嗯，你知道，李现在在俄克拉荷马州工作，我们要去探望他，他给我们找了一家非常好的Airbnb，让我们全家人住在一起。这样我们就能散开，每个人都能睡个好觉。你会感觉像在家里一样，
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I do know this. Yes, I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right. Yeah.
即使你身处异地。天哪，我可不想和全家人挤在一个房间里。这就是我再也不想住酒店的原因。没错，因为你们都挤在一起，还要共用一个浴室。是的，我喜欢空间。我喜欢冰箱，一个真正的冰箱。你知道我喜欢吃零食。我确实知道。是的，我不想叫客房服务。我想伸手就能拿到。没错。没错。
Everyone we're ladies who Airbnb, I guess, for your next adventure for your next vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. pepper sauce poured with ease, and if smoky strips of bacon make burgers better, you'll love our cheesy jalapeno and bacon quarter pounder. Get this beefy, bold, bacony, melty mouthful only at McDonald's for a limited time. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office
各位，我想我们是“Airbnb女士”。对于你的下一次冒险，下一次假期，也许可以考虑Airbnb。胡椒酱倒得轻松自如，如果烟熏培根能让汉堡更美味，那你一定会爱上我们的芝士墨西哥辣椒培根四分之一磅汉堡。这种牛肉味十足、大胆、培根味浓郁、入口即化的美味，仅在麦当劳限时供应。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周我们都会深入挖掘《办公室》的世界，
with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello there. Hi everyone. We have such a big episode of Office Ladies 6.0 today because you know on Monday it was the 20th anniversary of The Office and we thought well we have to celebrate it today. This is a big milestone. A lot of
通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事。我们是《办公室女士6.0》。大家好。嘿，各位。今天我们有非常重要的《办公室女士6.0》节目，因为你知道周一是《办公室》开播20周年纪念日，我们想，嗯，今天我们一定要庆祝一下。这是一个重要的里程碑。你们很多人
you wrote us about this. Bethany C from Denver Denver, Colorado said, Hello ladies, the first episode of The Office aired in the US on March 24th, 2005, which means this year will mark 20 years. Is there a plan to celebrate the big anniversary? And Brianna S. from Athens, Ohio said, Something I would be interested in as possible episodes now that you're doing character breakdowns would be a cast or crew breakdown.
都写信给我们提到了这件事。来自科罗拉多州丹佛市的贝瑟尼·C说，嘿，女士们，《办公室》第一集于2005年3月24日在美国播出，这意味着今年是20周年纪念。有什么庆祝这个大纪念日的计划吗？来自俄亥俄州雅典市的布丽安娜·S说，既然你们现在在做角色分析，我可能感兴趣的一件事是演员或剧组的分析。
For example, how about all about Greg Daniels? Well, Bethany and Brianna, you are in luck. Today we are celebrating the 20th anniversary of The Office with special guest, Greg Daniels. It was so wonderful talking with Greg. We had such a great conversation about 20 years of The Office. Not only did we ask him about how he came to run the show,
例如，聊聊格雷格·丹尼尔斯怎么样？好吧，贝瑟尼和布丽安娜，你们真幸运。今天我们邀请了特别嘉宾格雷格·丹尼尔斯，共同庆祝《办公室》20周年。和格雷格聊天真是太棒了。我们进行了非常精彩的谈话，聊了《办公室》的20年历程。我们不仅问了他当初是如何接手这部剧的，
but we also reflect on so many wonderful memories. Yeah, as this anniversary was approaching, Angela and I, we both went back and we rewatched the pilot episode of The Office. It was so interesting. We were like the people who go back and start from the beginning in a way. I know.
还回顾了许多美好的回忆。是的，随着周年纪念日的临近，我和安吉拉都回去重温了《办公室》的试播集。太有趣了。我们就像那些回去从头开始看的人一样。我知道。
I watched the original broadcast and then I went and watched the super fan version because I was curious. I did the same thing and we talk with Greg about it. And you know guys, I went back into some of my, well I guess it's not my digital clutter, it's my actual clutter. I went into my bin of photos,
我看了最初的播出，然后我又去看了粉丝超级版，因为我很好奇。我也做了同样的事情，我们和格雷格聊了这件事。而且你们知道吗，我翻看了我的一些——好吧，我想那不是我的数字杂物，而是我实际的杂物。我去了我的照片箱，
I found the photos from the pilot, from the party we went to after the pilot. Some of those, Jenna, we shared in our book, The Office BFFs. Some we used in a reel that Josh made for us to celebrate the 20th anniversary. Some I didn't put in either. I'm going to share them in stories. But then you guys, are you ready for this? I went to my journal that is titled, what's it called, Jenna? Office Early Days. Uh-huh.
我找到了试播集时的照片，还有我们试播集后参加的派对照片。珍娜，其中一些我们分享在我们的书《办公室闺蜜》里了。有些我们用在乔希为我们制作的庆祝20周年的短片里了。有些我两边都没放。我要在动态里分享它们。但是，伙计们，准备好了吗？我找到了我的日记，标题是，叫什么来着，珍娜？《办公室早期日子》。嗯哼。
I have a journal entry that I can't wait to share with you guys. It is from our very first day of filming. That is nuts to me. Are you ready? You told me you found this and I can't wait. Well, I've been holding on to this for a while because I found it after we had already broke down the pilot. And I was like, oh, dang it.
我有一篇日记，迫不及待想和你们分享。那是我们拍摄的第一天。对我来说这简直太疯狂了。准备好了吗？你告诉过我你找到了这个，我等不及了。嗯，我把它保存了一段时间，因为我是在我们分析完试播集之后才发现它的。当时我就想，哦，该死。
So here we go. September 20th, 2004, 7.30 a.m. First day of shooting of The Office. That is written in blue ink. That means you wrote this on the set of The Office. Oh, yeah, it's gonna be very clear. Okay, so at 7.30 a.m. I wrote, first day of shooting of The Office.
所以，我们开始吧。2004年9月20日，早上7:30。《办公室》开拍第一天。这是用蓝色墨水写的。这意味着你是当时在《办公室》片场写的。哦，是的，会非常清晰。好吧，早上7:30，我写道，《办公室》开拍第一天。
That's in blue ink. Next line is in black ink. This is the best job ever. Next line is in red ink. I have all of these pens on my desk, so I'm trying them all out. Oh my gosh. Okay, next line is in black ink. My call time was 5 a. Okay. The next line is in black ink.
那是蓝色墨水。下一行是黑色墨水。这是有史以来最好的工作。下一行是红色墨水。我的桌上有所有的笔，所以我都在试用。哦天哪。好吧，下一行是黑色墨水。我的通告时间是早上5点。好吧。下一行是黑色墨水。
My call time was 5 a.m. So sleepy exclamation point. I didn't even really fall asleep in the first place. 1240 p.m. in red ink. New timestamp, new ink. Am so sleepy but am having the time of my life. 435 p.m. in black ink. Am absolutely so punchy.
我的通告时间是早上5点。好困，感叹号。我甚至根本没睡着。下午12:40，红色墨水。新的时间戳，新的墨水。好困，但正过着我一生中最美好的时光。下午4:35，黑色墨水。简直太兴奋了。
Drew a black heart. Okay. Almost asleep with my eyes open. Oh, just got flowers from my agent. Congrats, et cetera. Very nice. Okay, next thing. Blue ink. Here is the letterhead from our fake company. Also one of my call
画了一个黑色的心。好吧。几乎睁着眼睛睡着了。哦，刚收到经纪人送的花。祝贺之类的。非常好。好吧，下一件事。蓝色墨水。这是我们虚构公司的信笺。还有我的通告单。
sheets. And then you taped it inside? Oh stop it. It's so cute. Alright next entry in black ink. Gosh I so want this show to be a success. Next entry. I'm already looking forward to Christmas. Is that nuts? It's my favorite time of the I want this show to be a success. Next entry. I'm already looking forward to Christmas. Is that nuts? It's my favorite time of the year. I can't wait to decorate.
然后你把它贴在里面了？哦，停下。太可爱了。好吧，下一条记录，黑色墨水。天哪，我太希望这部剧能成功了。下一条记录。我已经开始期待圣诞节了。这疯了吗？这是我一年中最喜欢的时光。我等不及要装饰了。
Wow. That was a hard pivot. I know, I know. It's what was on your mind. Okay, are you ready? Final entry from the first day. My pantyhose are cutting me in half. How do women wear these all the time? Seriously?
哇。那是个大转折。我知道，我知道。那是你当时脑子里想的。好吧，准备好了吗？第一天的最后一篇条目。我的连裤袜要把我勒成两半了。女人们怎么能整天穿这个？认真的吗？
Question mark exclamation point. I want to ditch them. Exclamation point. And you did. And I did. There you go. First day on the set of the office. That's pretty amazing. Sam, I can't believe you didn't pop on to give me a hard time about all the different color ink. I didn't want to interrupt, but it was killing me. Why was I so excited about all my different pins? I don't know. I like to think it's your different moods.
问号感叹号。我想脱掉它们。感叹号。而你确实这么做了。我确实做了。就是这样。在《办公室》片场的第一天。这太神奇了。萨姆，我不敢相信你没跳出来调侃我换这么多颜色的墨水。我不想打断，但这快把我憋坏了。我当时为什么对那么多笔那么兴奋？我不知道。我喜欢认为那是你不同的心情。
Well, Alison Jones found something in her clutter as well, and she sent it to me out of the blue. She found the casting descriptions for the main cast. These were written by Greg Daniels, and I thought it would be so fun to read them. I can't wait to hear these. I knew you got them, but I haven't heard them yet. And I thought what would be fun is as you read one, I would play some of the audition tapes that are online, and we can go back and forth.
嗯，艾莉森·琼斯在她的杂物里也发现了一些东西，她毫无征兆地发给了我。她找到了主要演员的选角描述。这些是格雷格·丹尼尔斯写的，我觉得读出来会很有趣。我等不及要听了。我知道你拿到了，但我还没听过。我想有趣的是，你读一个的时候，我会播放网上的一些试镜带，我们可以穿插着看。
I love it. All right, let's start with Michael Scott. Here is how he is described. 34 to 44. Michael Scott is the manager of the office and the boastful, unreliable narrator of the documentary. He is a legend in his own mind who thinks he is a comic genius, fountain of business wisdom and his's cool friend.
我喜欢。好吧，我们从迈克尔·斯科特开始。这是他的描述：34到44岁。迈克尔·斯科特是办公室经理，也是纪录片中爱吹牛、不可靠的叙述者。他是个自认的传奇，自认为是喜剧天才、商业智慧的源泉和他的酷朋友。
He believes in his version of reality with the sincere enthusiasm of a nine-year-old child thinking he can do karate. However, the documentary reveals the truth. He is a buffoon, a pathetic mid-level bureaucrat overdue for a midlife crisis, whom decent people pity as a quote, sad little man, when his inappropriate behavior hasn't appalled them into silence. Horribly overconfident, he is a train wreck of bad leadership characteristics only redeemed a bit by his childish enthusiasm. Despite continual proofs that he's an ass, he clings shamelessly to his deluded self-image like a shipwrecked survivor clinging to a scrap of wood. And then it says, we need an actor who can play a juicy comic character, someone with an expressive face to get a laugh on a smug look. Someone with the heart of a nine-year-old, but who plays between 34 and 44.
他以一个以为自己会空手道的九岁孩子那种真诚的热情相信他自己的现实版本。然而，纪录片揭示了真相。他是个小丑，一个可悲的中层官僚，早该经历中年危机，体面的人会怜悯他，称他为“可悲的小人物”，当他不恰当的行为没有让他们震惊到沉默的时候。极度自负，他是一场糟糕领导力的灾难，只有他那幼稚的热情让他稍微挽回了一点点。尽管有持续的证明他是个混蛋，但他还是像遭遇海难的幸存者抓住一片木板一样无耻地坚持着他那自欺欺人的形象。然后它说，我们需要一个能扮演一个多汁喜剧角色的演员，一个有表现力的脸，能用得意的表情博得一笑。一个有着九岁孩子心脏的人，但表现出的年龄在34到44岁之间。
Someone whose face and physique do not command natural respect, i.e. not buff and handsome, boyish, not rugged, capable of high-spirited, sunny energy, as well as small, specific acting." as well as small specific acting. Wow, that's so much information. Yeah. Well, here is Steve reading for Michael. This is just a portion of his audition, but let's hear it. Actually, people say I am the best boss they've ever had, the world's greatest boss, given to me.
一个长相和体格不能让人自然产生敬畏的人，即不强壮也不帅气，孩子气，不粗犷，既能有精神饱满、阳光的能量，也能有细腻、具体的表演。哇，信息量太大了。是的。好吧，这是史蒂夫为迈克尔试镜。这只是他试镜的一部分，让我们听听。实际上，人们说我是他们遇到过最好的老板，世界上最伟大的老板。
They go, Michael, we have never worked in a place like this before. I mean, you are a riot. You get the best out of us. And I say, well, quesara sera. And if it's true, awesome. When's quesara sera? What is Kesarasara? Well, it's kind of a non sequitur, I've been told. It's kind of, you know what kind of filler words?
他们说，迈克尔，我们以前从未在这样的地方工作过。我的意思是，你太搞笑了。你让我们发挥出了最好的一面。我说，好吧，顺其自然。如果是真的，太棒了。什么是顺其自然？什么是顺其自然？好吧，这是一种非逻辑的说法，我被告知。这是一种，你知道，某种填充词？
Have you ever heard of filler words? It's kind of like that. You know, Kesarasara, if I had to define what it meant, I'd say, in what context did I use it, just saying? Isn't that so great? And I love that you can hear Ken Quapus. Yes. Well, what's so crazy about it is that it starts and it just sounds like an episode of The Office. Like it just sounds like he's, it doesn't sound like an audition at all. I know. But then you see how our auditions went, which is that we would do the prepared material
你听说过填充词吗？就有点像那样。你知道，顺其自然，如果我必须定义它的含义，我会说，我在什么语境下用它，只是说说？这不是太棒了吗？而且我喜欢你能听到肯·夸普斯的笑声。是的。令人疯狂的是，它一开头听起来就像《办公室》的一集。听起来完全不像试镜。我知道。但后来你看到我们的试镜是怎么进行的，我们会做准备好的材料，
and then Ken would just throw a question at us. Like what's case for Roswell? Yeah, exactly. It's a filler word. Yeah. It's just one of those filler words. So great. Are you ready to hear about Dwight Schrute?
然后肯会直接向我们抛出一个问题。比如什么是顺其自然？是的，完全正确。这是一个填充词。是的。它只是那些填充词之一。太棒了。准备好听关于德怀特·舒特了吗？
Yes. Here is how Greg described him in the breakdown. Dwight is the team leader and Michael Scott's sidekick. He really admires Michael Scott, although it is unclear if this is due to Scott's personality or Dwight's officious inclination to look up to whoever is above him in the hierarchy. Dwight is obsessed with survival,
是的。这是格雷格在分析中描述他的方式。德怀特是团队领导，也是迈克尔·斯科特的副手。他真的很钦佩迈克尔·斯科特，尽管不清楚这是由于斯科特的个性，还是德怀特那种官僚主义的倾向，即仰视任何在等级制度中高于他的人。德怀特痴迷于生存，
personal security tactics, and other grandiose nerd action fantasies, probably because he got his ass kicked a lot as a kid. A volunteer policeman on the weekends, he takes any excuse to go on a power trip in the office. Yet his survival training appears to be more Gilligan's Island than Green Berets. Although aggressively horny, training appears to be more Gilligan's Island than Green Berets. Although
个人安全策略以及其他宏大的书呆子动作幻想，可能是因为他小时候经常被打。周末是一名志愿警察，他利用任何借口在办公室进行权力之旅。然而，他的生存训练似乎更像是《吉利根岛》而不是绿色贝雷帽。虽然表现出极度的色情，但
aggressively horny, he has no idea how to behave with women. His unpleasant social habits and annoying personality suggest an unsocialized loner, a sort of Caliban or Gollum. If stuck in an elevator, he would probably start drinking his own urine after 10 minutes. I have just like side note, just this idea that Dwight gets stuck in an elevator goes all the way back to the breakdown. I love that. Like how Dwight would behave in an elevator. All right, going on. He said, his lack of social skills render him the butt of office jokes and thus unbearable. If Scott is redeemed by having the heart of a nine-year-old, then Dwight can perhaps be
他根本不知道如何与女性相处。他令人不快的社交习惯和恼人的个性表明他是一个未被社会化的孤独者，一种类似卡利班或咕噜的东西。如果被困在电梯里，他可能会在10分钟后就开始喝自己的尿。我有一个旁注，只是这个德怀特被困在电梯里的想法可以追溯到人物分析。我喜欢那个。就像德怀特在电梯里会表现的那样。好的，继续。他说，他缺乏社交技能使他成为办公室笑话的靶子，因此让人无法忍受。如果斯科特因为拥有一颗九岁孩子的心而被救赎，那么德怀特也许可以因为他内心十几岁的极客而被怜悯。我们需要一个在作为极客时可信的人，除了通过与角色的完全认同之外，没有想要被喜欢或取悦观众的愿望的人。这太像雷恩了。我得认为雷恩一走进房间，他们就想，好吧，该死，那就是德怀特。一个在说出疯狂话语时对自己显得很合理的人。谁理解这种一本正经的喜剧。20多岁到30岁。哦天哪。好吧，现在我们必须听听雷恩为德怀特试镜。通过在上面撒尿。没错，它在《美国红十字会急救指南》里。所以因为在水槽里撒尿而惹上麻烦对我来说完全不公平。太棒了。嗯，我知道还有更多的片段，但这就是你能从网上找到的。你立刻就能听出他就是德怀特。我觉得我们所有人都是这样，
pitied for his interior teenage geek. We need someone who can be believable as a geek, someone who has no desire to be likable or please an audience except through total identification with his character. This is so Rain. I have to think the minute Rain walked in the room they were like, well crap, that's Dwight. Someone who can seem reasonable to himself while saying insane things. Who understands the comedy of playing it straight. Late 20s to 30s. Oh my gosh. Okay, well now we have to hear Rain auditioning for Dwight. by whizzing on it. True, it is in the first aid guidebook
因为他内心的少年极客而被人同情。我们需要一个能够让人相信他是极客的人，一个除了通过与角色完全融合之外，没有欲望去讨好观众或取悦观众的人。这太像雷恩了。我敢肯定雷恩走进房间的那一刻，他们就在想，糟了，那就是德怀特。一个在说出疯狂的话时，还能让自己看起来合情合理的人。一个懂得一本正经地演戏所带来的喜剧效果的人。年龄在20多岁到30岁之间。天哪。好吧，现在我们得听听雷恩为德怀特试镜的内容了。在上面尿尿。没错，急救指南里确实有这一条
from the American Red Cross Association. So it's totally unfair for me to get in trouble for whizzing in the sink. Amazing. Well, I know there's so much more footage, but that's what you can pull from online. And you hear him immediately as Dwight. I felt like as all of us,
这在我刚才回去重温试播集时是真的，我觉得雷恩饰演的德怀特是我们所有人中第一天起就最成熟的。第一天，是的。是的。好吧。接下来是吉姆·纳尔逊的人物分析。原名是吉姆·纳尔逊。吉姆是办公室的一名销售代表，
and this was true when I went back just now and rewatched the pilot, I think Rain as Dwight was the most fully realized of all of us from day one. Day one, yeah. Yeah. All right. Next up is the breakdown for Jim Nelson. The original name was Jim Nelson. Jim is a sales rep in the office
不得不与德怀特共用工作空间。他是一个普通、体面、有品位的人，过着安静而绝望的生活。他喜欢人，是一个很好的倾听者，想成为一名心理学家。嗯。他聪明的讽刺和对镜头的反应是他抵御周围庸俗的微小防御，尽管它们让接待员帕姆发笑。你希望他在爱情和工作中更果断一些。在和帕姆玩耍之后，他在办公室的主要乐趣是利用他优越的社交和情感技能来恶作剧德怀特。尽管你感觉到当他沉溺于这种不成熟的冲动时，他正让环境打败他。我们需要一个讨人喜欢的人，30岁左右，
who has to share a workspace with Dwight. He is an ordinary, decent person with good taste, leading a life of quiet desperation. He likes people, is a good listener, and wanted to be a psychologist. Well. His clever sarcasm and takes to the camera are little defense against the vulgarity that
能通过挑眉或对镜头反应博得一笑的人。他需要看起来足够顺眼，让你支持他去追女孩，而又不至于帅得过分。虽然被他的平凡和糟糕的发型掩盖，但吉姆是浪漫男主角。他们写了糟糕的发型？
surrounds him, although they make Pam the receptionist laugh. You wish he would be more assertive in love and at work. After playing with Pam, his chief enjoyment in the office is using his superior social and emotional skills to prank Dwight. Although you get the sense that when he indulges in his immature impulses, he is letting the environment defeat him. We need someone likable, around 30,
是的。好吧，这是约翰为吉姆试镜。我是销售代表，这意味着我的工作是通过电话与客户沟通数量、纸张类型、我们是否能供应给他们、他们是否能付款。我光是谈论这个就觉得自己在浪费时间。老实说，这意味着……我的意思是，这听起来就像是从剧中来的，老实说。
who can get laughs by raising an eyebrow or doing a take to the camera. He needs to be pleasant looking enough for you to root for him to get the girl without being a hunk in any way. Although hidden by his ordinariness and bad haircut, Jim is the romantic lead. They wrote in bad haircut?
我知道。那是一个试镜带。好吧。最后，这是帕姆·比斯利的分析。年龄范围是26到29岁。它写着，帕姆是接待员，也是吉姆的朋友。帕姆体面、合理、友好。她有着善良的幼儿园老师或未来妈妈的风度。
Yeah. All right, here is John auditioning for Jim. I'm a sales rep, which means that my job is to speak to clients on the phone about quantity, type of paper, whether we can supply it to them, whether they can pay for it. And I'm boring myself just talking about it. To be honest, it's... I mean, that just sounds like it's To be honest, it's, uh... I mean, that just sounds like it's from the show, honestly.
她是一个有幽默感的普通女性。她允许她吵闹的老板和未婚夫欺负她，但在保护朋友时，她能展现出工人阶级的强硬。她不是愤世嫉俗或自作聪明的人，尽管她表达不同意见的方式是一种温和的讽刺。她不傲慢、不华丽、也不显眼地性感，但比起其他办公室职员，她很可爱，她喜欢和吉姆玩耍，吉姆比她的未婚夫罗伊更了解她。
I know. That was an audition tape. All right. Finally, here is Pam Beasley's breakdown. 26 to 29 was the age range. And it says, Pam is the receptionist and Jim's friend. Pam is decent, reasonable, and friendly. She has the manner of a nice kindergarten teacher or a future mom.
吉姆和帕姆如果不被扔进办公室，可能不会相遇，但他们已经成为了真正的朋友，他们的调情比他们承认的要认真。帕姆需要温柔、善良且脆弱。也很漂亮，但绝对不是那种让人回头的人，更像是一种可爱、容易接近的漂亮。一个可以在轻描淡写中传达讽刺的打工族邻家女孩类型，却带有一丝悲剧色彩，帕姆是另一位浪漫女主角。哦天哪，当你观看你的试镜带时，当你观看试播集时，珍娜，你立刻就抓住了帕姆的精髓。你确实做到了。让我们听听你为帕姆试镜。我希望他们除掉我。
She is an ordinary woman with a sense of humor. She allows her loudish boss and fiance to push her around some, but she can exhibit flashes of working class toughness in protecting her friends. She's not cynical or a smart ass, although her way of disagreeing is a gentle sarcasm. She's not arrogant or glamorous or overtly sexy, but she is cute compared to the other office workers and she loves to play with Jim, who understands her better than Roy, her fiancé.
因为那样我可能会真的动起来去做点什么。因为我不认为很多小女孩的梦想是长大后当接待员。我不知道我要做什么，但无论做什么，那必须是一个职业规划，而不仅仅是又一份随意的零工。吉姆的建议是，与其爬上一个你不喜欢的梯子，不如待在你想爬的梯子底层。是的，我记得做了那个。她甚至在试镜时都没有引用罗伊的话。没错。
Jim and Pam probably would not have met without being thrown together in the office, but they have become true friends and their flirting is more serious than they acknowledge. Pam needs to be soft and kind and vulnerable. Pretty too, but definitely not a head-turner, more of a likable, accessible pretty. A working-world, girl-next-door type who can deliver sarcasm with a light touch, yet a touch of the tragic waif, Pam is the other romantic lead. Oh man, when you watch your audition tape, when you watch the pilot, Jenna, you got Pam right away. You just did. And let's hear you audition for Pam. I hope they get rid of me.
好吧，接下来我有两批较短的多个角色试镜片段。我们有BJ演瑞安，克雷格演达里尔，大卫演罗伊，戴夫演托德，梅洛拉演简。让我们听听他们。好的，我喜欢外国电影。我读《纽约客》，喜欢莎士比亚。你碰巧看到停车场里的邓德·米夫林旗了吗？那很鼓舞人心。我想我要把它盖在我的棺材上。嘿，宝贝，你这儿有什么？呃，是的，你介意我和这些人去喝一杯吗？呃，不，不，让我们，让我们回家。
Because then I might actually get off my ass and do something. Because I don't think it's many little girls' dreams to grow up and be a receptionist. And I don't know what I'm going to do, but whatever it is, it's got to be a career move, not just another arbitrary job. Jim's advice was that it's better to be at the bottom of a ladder that you want to climb than halfway up one you don't. Yeah, I remember doing that. She's not quoting Roy even in the audition. That's right.
我认为这只是个噱头，真的。你知道，休闲星期五，有一天你放松一下，那太可悲了。迈克尔？继续。我们能不谈裁员吗？好吧，我们早晚都得谈。休闲星期五，有一天你放松一下。那太可悲了。迈克尔。继续。我们能不谈裁员吗？好吧，我们早晚都得谈。是的。
All right, next up I have two batches of shorter clips of multiple characters auditioning. We have BJ for Ryan, Craig for Daryl, David for Roy, Dave for Todd, and Melora for Jan. Let's hear them. Okay, I'm into foreign films. I read The New Yorker, love Shakespeare. Did you happen to see the Dunder Mifflin flag out in the parking lot? It's inspiring. I think I'm wanting on my coffin. Hey, baby, what do you got here? Uh, yeah, would you mind if I went up for a drink with these guys? Uh, no, no, let's, let's, let's go home.
但现在，我们必须决定是把斯坦福的人并入这个分部，还是反之亦然？那些只是每个人试镜的快速小片段。那另一批是什么？你有你们其余的人吗？我有布莱恩演凯文，奥斯卡演奥斯卡，安吉拉演帕姆，莱斯利演斯坦利，凯特演梅雷迪思。
It's a gimmick, I think, really. You know, Casual Friday, one day you let your hair down, that's pathetic. Michael? Go on. Can we not talk about downsizing? Well, we have to sooner or later. Casual Friday, one day you let your hair down. That's pathetic. Michael. Go on. Can we not talk about downsizing? Are we have to sooner or later? Yes.
你昨晚看电视了吗？我不知道，电影看得直通。我看了那个《特殊受害者》，没见过那个该死的重播。对我来说不是这样。我没看过。这是一个信任问题。是沟通。
But right now, what we have to decide is do you fold Stanford people into this branch or vice versa? Those are just quick little snippets of each person auditioning. And then what's the other batch? Do you have the rest of you guys? I have Brian for Kevin Oscar for Oscar Angela for Pam Leslie for Stanley and Kate for Meredith
你信任我吗？你信任我吗？是还是不是？是的。我信任你。我喜欢那个。因为你不常得到既浪漫又节俭的东西。所以这还在进行。我说如果总公司想来这里干涉，你可能会破坏我的冷静，而且
Would you watch on TV last night? I didn't know right through the movie. I watched that special victim SVU never seen that Friggin repeat Not for me. I hadn't seen it. It is a question of trust. It's communication.
如果有人要这样做的话，那就是我。是的，但迈克尔，如果他们在这里裁员怎么办？那不会发生。这可能超出你的控制，迈克尔。有什么你想加进议程的事情吗？就是那样？凯特只有一句台词。有什么你想加进议程的事情吗？
Do you trust me? Do you trust me? Yes or no? Yes. I trust you. I like that. Because it's not often that you get something that's both romantic and thrifty. So there's that going. I said if corporate wants to come here and interfere, you may mess with my chill and
好吧，这些只是小片段。我们的试镜要长得多。我们即兴发挥了很多，做了所有这些不同的表演，但这才是我们能接触到的。而且我没有我试镜安吉拉·马丁的片段。当我们做关于安吉拉·马丁的一切时，我们可能不得不去找戴夫·罗杰斯。哦，我们应该这么做。看看我们能不能搞定那个。
I am if anyone's going to. Yeah, but Michael, what if they do downsize here? It's not going to happen. It could be out of your hands, Michael. Was there anything that you wanted to add to the agenda? That was it? Kate just got one line. Is there anything you wanted to add to the agenda?
我知道，那肯定会进入档案库。好吧，听着，大家，我们要休息一下，回来之后，我们将对剧集主创格雷格·丹尼尔斯进行一次精彩的采访。[“Fizz忠诚度计划”] 有了Fizz忠诚度计划，仅仅拥有一个手机套餐你就能获得奖励。你知道，发短信之类的。如果你的手机套餐没有获得额外数据和现金减免等奖励，那你就不在Fizz。
Well they're just little clips. Our auditions were much longer. We improvised a whole bunch and did all these different takes, but that's what we have access to. And I don't have me auditioning for Angela Martin. We might have to hit up Dave Rogers for that when we do all about Angela Martin. Oh, we should. Let's see if we can get a hold of that.
今天就切换吧。条件适用。详情请见Fizz.ca。你在消灭你的账单吗？击败你的每月还款。每个月全额且准时地支付。从账单支付者升级为奖励猎手。条款和条件适用。不断寻找新的、创造性的方式来加大赌注，你杀死的第一个，让其他人知道你来了，我想要他们全部。奥斯卡奖得主拉米·马雷克，奥斯卡奖提名者劳伦斯·菲什伯恩，业余爱好者，仅在影院上映，我是9月11日。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，欢迎格雷格。你在这里。你曾经在常规的《办公室女士》节目中，现在
I know, that would be going into the archives for sure. Well, listen everyone, we're gonna take a break and when we come back, we have a fantastic interview with showrunner Greg Daniels. ["The Fizz Loyalty Program"] With The Fizz Loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz.
你在《办公室女士6.0》。你是怎么直接跳到6.0而不是2.0的？格雷格，这是一个冷门知识。哦，那是米歇尔的一个笑话。是的。这次采访进行得不顺利。不。所以等等，这是什么节目？我想我看过这个。在《辣妹》那集中，迈克尔说凯蒂是帕姆6.0。对。对。所以什么？太粗鲁了。
Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at Fizz.ca. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. details at phys.ca. full and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. That constantly finds new and inventive ways to up the stakes the first one you kill you let the other ones know you're coming I want them all Academy Award winner Rummy Malik an Academy Award nominee Lawrence Fishburne the amateur Only in theaters and I'm act saber 11th Greg Daniels Welcome Greg. Here you are. You were on the regular Office Ladies and now
这真的让我质疑为什么我们把我们的节目命名为一个即使是创作者都不记得的冷门知识。我喜欢它。对于那些不知道的人，我喜欢这种神秘感。不，不是。我们很高兴你能在这里。这对《办公室》的世界来说是一个大场合。这是一个我们走到一起来庆祝的巨大周年纪念。这是《办公室》的20周年纪念。疯狂。疯狂。但真的疯狂吗？现在情况是这样的，我意识到很多时候人们会说，我想那种预期的反应是，哦，我不敢相信这么长时间过去了。但
you're on Office Ladies 6.0. How did you jump to 6.0 instead of 2.0? Greg, this is a deep cut. Oh, that's a joke from Michelle. Yes. This interview is not going well. No. So wait, what show is this? I think I saw this. In Hot Girl, Michael says that Katie is Pam 6.0. Right. Right. So what? So rude.
然后我会质疑，那对我来说不太对劲。我就想，不，我觉得对我来说感觉已经过了很长时间了。所以我不知道，我不知道，对你来说感觉如何？我的意思是，我认为这是一个组合拼盘。我认为有时感觉就像一个完全不同的存在。
This is really making me question why we named our show a deep cut that is so deep that even the creator does not recall. I like it. I like the mystery for those that don't know. No, it's not. We are so thrilled to have you here. This is a big occasion in the world of The Office. This is a huge anniversary that we've come here together to celebrate. It is the 20th anniversary of The Office. Crazy. Crazy. Is it crazy though? Now here's the thing, I realized that for a lot of times that people would say that I think the sort of expected thing is like, oh I can't believe so much time has gone by. But
那是很久以前的一章。有时我们会听到一个片段或重温一集，我会想起，你知道，我们那周在做什么，然后你就回到了那个时刻。所以这在某种程度上有点像翻阅旧的家庭照片集。我有一个奇怪的经历，因为我们正在制作《山丘之王》的第14季和第15季。哦天哪。如果你能想象的话。哇。那是一部老得多的剧。是的。所以我正在为那些角色写剧本，你知道，而且在我们的剧开播之前，我真的没有想过他们。我非常高兴能稍微
then I was questioning like that didn't really sit right with me. And I was like, no, I think it feels like it's been a long time to me. So I don't know. I don't know, how does it feel to you? I mean, I think it's a combo platter. I think sometimes it feels like a whole different existence.
再次和这些角色谈话。这在我脑子里是一件非常嬉皮士的事情，但我就想，哦天哪，佩吉。是的，那是……我很久没跟你说话了。没错。珍娜有一次这么说。你说，我们都保持着联系。
It was such a chapter so long ago. And then sometimes we will hear a clip or revisit an episode and I'll remember, you know, what we were doing that week or it and then you're right back there. So it's a little bit like going through an old family album of photos in a way. I had a weird experience because we are doing season 14 and 15 of King of the Hill. Oh my gosh. If you can imagine that. Wow. That's a much older show. Yeah. And so I was writing for those characters and you know and I hadn't really thought about them since before our show started. And I was just so happy to kind of
演员们，我们有这个短信群。但你就说，我想念梅雷迪思和凯文，我想念德怀特。是的，我见到雷恩。但我不能再和德怀特说话了。我很想和那个家伙谈谈。一些奇怪的梦。你只是需要在睡觉前吃那种奇怪的芝士味的东西。我确实会做梦梦到我们又在拍摄了。是的，我又回到了片场，我们都在那里。有时梦境是我们在制作这部剧。但有时梦境是我们创造了一个重聚节目。就像现代一样。所以我做了这两个梦。嗯。其中一个是噩梦吗？
talk to the characters again. It was very kind of hippie dippy thing going on in my head, but I was like, oh my gosh, Peggy. Yes, that's what- I haven't talked to you in ages. That's right. Jenna said that one time. You said, we have all stayed in touch.
实际上，重聚那个有点像噩梦。所以值得参考一下。通常是我，通常包裹在那样的想法里，比如，哦天哪，我没有，我答应了这件事，但我忘了准备。我不记得怎么做帕姆了，我不知道我在做什么。是的。嗯，我觉得拥有一部你真正关心的在播节目压力巨大，因为它可以在最后一秒走下坡路，每个人都可能生气，你可能会毁了它。当我们最终停止制作这部剧的新剧集时，对我来说是一种非常好的感觉。
The cast, we have this text thread. But you were like, I miss Meredith and Kevin, and I miss Dwight. Yeah, I see Rain. But I don't get to talk to Dwight again. I'd love to talk to that guy. Some weird dreams. You just got to eat like weird cheesy things right
所以我当时想，OK，安全了。做到了。把它放在架子上。安息吧，是的。是的。我仍然记得当我，你知道，珍娜和我为这一集做的事情之一就是我们回去重温了试播集
before bed. I do have dreams where we're shooting again. Yeah, and I'm back on set and we're all there. And sometimes the dream is like we're making the show. But then sometimes the dream is that we've created a reunion show. It's like present day. So I've had both of these dreams. Hmm. And is one of them a nightmare?
我们回去看了试播集的粉丝超级版，因为我们俩都没看过那个。但我仍然，就像我看它的时候，回到我脑海中的是那种感觉，当我们早上走进舞台时，就像在我们开始拍摄之前，我们走过那条走廊，我们走后门，你知道，
Actually, the reunion one's kind of a nightmare. So take that for what it's worth. It's usually me, it's usually wrapped up in that idea of like, oh my gosh, I didn't, I said yes to this and I forgot to prepare. And I don't remember how to be Pam and I don't know what I'm doing. Yeah. Well, I feel like it's incredibly stressful to have a show that you really care about on the air because it can go south at the last second and and everybody can be mad, and you can ruin it. And it was such a nice feeling for me when we finally stopped producing new episodes of the show.
经过发型和化妆间。然后你突然就来到了邓德·米夫林办公室。我只是记得所有这些，我每天早上怎么走到我的桌子前，而且——你在想象第一季试播集里的办公室吗？还是——不，不，我是在想象……我总是想象我们大部分时间拍摄的那些。虽然我确实记得那个办公室，因为奥斯卡和我
So I was like, OK, it's safe. Did it. Put it on the shelf. Put to bed, yeah. Yeah. I still remember when I, you know, one of the things Jen and I did for this episode is we went and rewatched the pilot
太出丑了。就像，当我们在卡尔弗城拍摄时，我想我之前讲过这个故事，他和我决定走下楼梯，你知道，因为我们在楼上拍摄到我们的拖车，我们决定挥舞着手臂左到右，左到右，踢着腿，我们发出了这些声音，我们表现得太傻了，而在我们身后是泰瑞·温伯格和所有电视台的制片人。所有电视台的西装革履的人和我们甚至不认识的人。我们只知道他们很重要，因为他们都走进房间聊天之类的。奥斯卡就说，哦天哪，我们要被解雇了。
and we went and watched the super fan cut of the pilot because neither of us had seen that. And I still, like when I watched it, what came back to me was that feeling when we would walk on the stage in the morning, like before we started filming, and we'd walk down that corridor and we'd go in the back way, you know,
我们要被解雇了。所以我非常清楚地记得那栋楼，但我能记得走上片场的感觉。你记得那是什么感觉吗？哦是的，那是我希望我能做的事情。我希望，而且对我来说，它还在那里。我再也没有回到那些同样的舞台。我知道那里有，像，游戏节目之类的在拍摄。
past hair and makeup. And then you were all of a sudden in the Dunder Mifflin offices. I just remembered all of that, how I would walk to my desk in the morning and- Are you picturing the offices from the pilot in season one? Or- No, no, I'm picturing... I always picture the ones where we filmed the majority of the time. Although I do remember that office because Oscar and I
我想《费城永远阳光灿烂》在那里拍过。他们有，是的。这很奇怪。你记得在第一季吗，这可能是在试播集，但我记得要到达舞台，你必须走几级楼梯上去或几级楼梯下来，门口有一个非常低的混凝土天花板横梁，我会跑进片场给笔记，然后把头撞在这个横梁上。
made such asses of ourselves. Like, and when we filmed in Culver City, I think I've told this story before that he and I decided to walk down the stairs, you know, because we filmed upstairs to our trailers and we decided to walk swinging our arms left to right, left to right and kicking our legs and we made these noises and we were being so silly and behind us was Terry Weinberg and like all the network producers. All the network suits and people we didn't even know. We just knew they were important because they all went into the room to chat and stuff. And Oscar was like, oh God, we're fired.
然后最后他们放了一个大的橡胶缓冲器，上面写着，就像格雷格·丹尼尔斯纪念头撞器之类的，这样我就不会把自己撞晕了。那太搞笑了。试图冲进去。哦天哪。我的意思是，我从来没有这个问题，因为我从来不会。这不是你需要担心的那种问题。我清理门口非常容易。
We're fired. So I do remember that building very clearly, but I can remember what it felt like to walk on set. Do you remember what it felt like? Oh yeah, that is something I wish I could do. I wish that, and to me, it's still there. I've never been back to those same stages. I know that there's, like, game shows and stuff that shoot there.
你上次从头到尾看《办公室》的一集是什么时候？哦，我定期看它们。就像，你知道，它会出现，因为，正如你可能知道的那样，我正在从同一个纪录片团队制作下一个纪录片。是的。这个新节目。报纸。是的，报纸。所以很多时候我们会有一些我们想做得不同的事情，
I think always Sunny in Philadelphia shot there. They have, yeah. Which is weird. Do you remember in season one, and this might have been the pilot, but I remember that to get to the stage, you had to go up a couple of stairs or down a couple of stairs, and there was a very low concrete ceiling lintel at the doorway, and I would come running onto the set to give a note and bash my head against this lintel.
然后它们可能没有100%成功，我会回去检查原来的节目，我会想，哦，你知道，这就是为什么我们有相隔两英寸而不是一英寸的百叶窗，这样你就能看到人们的脸。哦，看到了。类似这样的事情。
And then eventually they put a big rubber bumper there that said, like, Greg Daniels Memorial head bumper or something so that I wouldn't knock myself out. That is so funny. Trying to rush in. Oh my gosh. I mean, I never had that problem because I never will. That's not a problem you have to worry about. I clear a doorway very easily.
那是我的镜头。是的，是的。我喜欢回去看这部剧。当然，你知道，我有一个15岁的女儿，她不知道那是什么，她正在看它。第一次看？是的，所以有时我会和她一起看。她正在猛刷
When's the last time you watched an episode of The Office start to finish? Oh, I watch them periodically. Like, you know, it comes up because, as you probably know, I'm doing the next documentary from the same documentary crew. Yes. This new show. The paper. Yes, the paper. And so a lot of times we'll have some things
所有那个时代的东西。她刚看完《杰茜驾到》。她刚开始看《发展受阻》。她就像……是的，那在电视喜剧方面其实是一个非常棒的时期。是的，我们和孩子们一起看了《老友记》，然后是《办公室》，这是我们大流行病期间观看的一部分。而且你知道，伊莎贝尔有一天转向我说，妈妈，你对每个人都太刻薄了。当我们看《办公室》时，我就想，我知道，但那不是我。但是是的，那对她来说有点难调和。我的孩子们还没看过《办公室》。
that we wanted to do differently and then they may not be 100% working out and I'll go back and I'll check the original show and I'll be like, oh, you know, that's why we had the blinds that are two inches apart and not one inch apart so you can see people's faces. Oh, see. Things like that.
我们现在正在看《摩登家庭》。是的，我们也看了那个。它太棒了。那是个好剧。我心想，会，好的，现在你们有了这种，就像有他们的谈话头版本，而且我知道他们对着镜头说话，
That's my shot. Yeah, yeah. I love going back and watching the show. And then of course, you know, I have a 15-year-old and she doesn't know what it is and she's watching it. For the first time? Yeah, so sometimes I'll watch it with her. And she's just plowing through
我心想，也许现在他们会想看《办公室》，但他们还没表示兴趣。他们会看到的。我发现当你消除他们每年赢得艾美奖的嫉妒心时，它确实改善了我观看《摩登家庭》的体验。是的，最近。我知道，我们确实和他们竞争了很多。我们确实如此。好吧，格雷格，我们总是问客人的一个问题，你是怎么得到创建《办公室》这份工作的？是的，好吧，基本上发生的事情是
all that era though. She just finished New Girl. She just started Arrested Development. She's just like... Yeah, that's a pretty great time in television comedy actually. Yeah, we did that part of our pandemic watch with our kids was Friends and then the office. And you know, Isabel just turned to me one day and said, mom, you're so mean to everybody. When we were watching the office, I was like, I know, but it's not me. But yeah, that was kind of hard for her to reconcile. My kids still haven't watched The Office.
我一直在做《山丘之王》，对我来说那是一次非常，你知道，很好的经历。那大概是在第八季左右，我并不真的需要在那里。我在20世纪的合同到期了。所以我是一名自由人，我正在寻找各种不同的东西作为下一个项目。关于《布偶秀》，我有过一些非常有趣的会议，别人后来做了，还有其他一些东西。我的经纪人给我寄了一盘磁带，一盘VHS录像带，叫《办公室》，在圣诞假期之前，大概是2003年，也许是12月。那是一个有点无聊的标题，我没看它。所以他在1月3日左右给我打电话说，好吧，如果不想做，我就把它发给下一个人。
We're watching Modern Family right now. Yes, we did watch that too. And it's so good. That's a good one. And I wondered, like, would, okay, now that you kind of have this, like there's their version of talking heads, and I know they speak to the camera,
如果我不想做的话。我就想，等一下，等一下。让我看看它。我今晚就看。我开始看它。我立刻爱上了它，六集的第一季。我熬夜把它们全看完了。
I'm like, maybe now they'll want to watch The Office, but they haven't expressed interest yet. They'll get there. I found that when you remove the jealousy of them winning the Emmy every year, it really improved my experience watching Modern Family. Yeah, recently. I know, we did go up against them a lot. We really did. All right, well Greg, one of the questions we always ask our guests, how did it come about that you got your job creating the office? Yes, okay, so basically what happened was
然后我就想，这东西绝对是天才。它感觉不像美国电视，但我非常渴望见到制作它的人，试着弄清楚它是怎么工作的，因为它是我见过的最好的东西。所以我最终在瑞奇和斯蒂芬来到美国面试改编它的人时，和他们见了一面。事实证明，我写过瑞奇·热维斯最喜欢的《辛普森一家》剧集，叫《荷马，坏人》。所以那很好，让我们开了一个好头。
I had been doing King of the Hill and it was very, you know, good experience for me. And it was probably around season eight and I was not really needed there. And my deal at 20th was up. And so I was a free agent and I was looking around at all sorts of different things to be the next project. And I had some real interesting meetings about the Muppet Show, which someone else did later and a couple of other things. And my agent sent me a tape, a VHS tape called The Office before Christmas break, like probably 2003, December maybe. And it was a little bit of a boring title and I didn't watch it. And then so he called me like January 3rd and said, all right, I'm going to send it to the next guy
我在《山丘之王》中带来的很多东西在现实主义和真诚方面与他们产生了共鸣，我想有时是这样。所以我们相处得很好。我说，OK，也许我会改编这个。当时，我们肯定认为它可能会在HBO或类似的地方播出。凯文·赖利很感兴趣，他在FX。凯文·赖利很感兴趣，他在FX。他非常懂这部剧，并且对此充满热情。
if you don't want to do it. And I was like, hang on, hang on. Let me watch it. And I'll watch it tonight. And I started it. And I just fell in love with it the first season of six episodes. And I stayed up late watching all of them.
所以我们当时想，好，FX会工作。那很酷。有边缘感。是的。有点前卫。它会做些不同的事情。所以我签下改编它。然后凯文去了NBC，他仍然想要它。然后西尔弗曼就说，是啊，是啊，让我们为NBC做吧。我就想，啊，你知道，它感觉不像NBC，你知道？NBC是多机位。所以走进它的时候，我当时想，好吧，如果我们为NBC做，我们可能不会赢，可能不会成功，但也许我们会把喜剧的船往我更想看到的漂浮方向推动，而不是完全的多机位方向。是的，所以我就是这样进入它的。
And then I was like, this stuff is absolutely brilliant. It doesn't feel like American TV, but I desperately want to meet the people who made it and just try and figure out how it works because it's the best thing, you know, that I had seen. So I ended up having a meeting with Ricky and Stephen when they came to the U.S. to interview people to adapt it. And it turned out that I had written Ricky Gervais' favorite Simpsons episode, which was called Homer, Bad Man. And so that was good, kind of getting us off on the right foot.
另一件事是我没认为原来的节目会在这儿播出。因为当你想到其他英国改编剧，像《全家福》，没有人见过《全家福》基于的英国节目。所以我只是认为很明显他们不会在我们播出前两个月运行英国原作。但他们确实这样做了。那很可怕。
And a lot of the stuff that I brought to King of the Hill had resonance with them in terms of the realism of the show and the sincerity, I guess, at times. And so we kind of hit it off. And so I said, OK, maybe I'll adapt this. And at the time, we definitely thought it would be probably on HBO or something like that. And Kevin Reilly was interested and he was at FX. And Kevin Reilly was interested and he was at FX. And he very much got the show and was enthusiastic about it.
好吧，我很好奇，从你的角度回顾，你什么时候知道我们的版本会坚持下去？或者你什么时候觉得我们是一个热门节目？嗯，那是在第二季发生的。我不知道你是否记得试播集，但我有一些关于试播集的话，我们都在拍摄停止后去了酒吧。
So we were like, all right, well, FX would work. That's pretty cool. Has an edge. Yeah. Kind of edgy. It'll do something different. And so I signed on to adapt it. And then Kevin went to NBC and he still wanted it. And then Silverman was like, yeah, yeah, let's Kevin went to NBC, and he still wanted it.
你记得那个吗？哦，我们说了再见。是的。我说我在下一份工作见你。我确实找到了那时的照片。是的。我正在告诉珍娜这个，因为当我们做我们的书时，
And then Silverman was like, yeah, yeah, let's do it for NBC. And I was like, ah, you know, it doesn't feel like NBC, you know? NBC was multicam. And so going into it, I was kind of like, all right, well, if we do it for NBC, we'll probably won't win, probably won't be successful, but maybe we'll like nudge the ship of comedy in a direction that I would rather see it float in than the complete multicam direction. And yeah, so that's how I got into it.
我们翻看了大量的照片，我们找到了试播集里的一些照片之类的事情。但我确实找到了我们都去的那家酒吧的照片。是的。我记得当时想，哇，那是一次有趣的经历。它完全值得。
And then the other thing was I did not think that the original show was ever going to air in America. Because when you think of other British adaptations, like All in the Family, like no one's ever seen the British show that All in the Family was based on. So I just figured it was obvious that they wouldn't run the British original here two months before we aired. Which they did. That was scary.
它不需要，它不需要成功才能让我找到拍摄那个试播集、见到大家的快乐，它非常好。我还记得在第一季结束时说了类似的话。我就想，好吧，这可能会失败。你知道吗？而且。
Well, I'm curious, looking back from your perspective, when did you know that our version was going to stick? Or when did you feel like we were sort of a hit show I guess? Well that'll happen season two. I don't know if you remember the pilot but I had a little some words after the pilot and we all went out to a bar I think when it stopped shooting.
我们第一季的六集。是的。我们非常简短的第一季。但是，你知道，在第二季非常令人兴奋，因为它在第二季一直在上升、上升、上升。到了第二季结束时，我想，像在《赌场之夜》，我们当时已经是一个成功的节目了，我想。你把那个归功于第二季的什么？
Do you remember that? Oh and we said goodbye. Yeah. I said I'll see you on the next job. I actually found pictures from that. Yeah. And I was telling Jenna this, because when we did our book,
你认为这是我们做出的改变吗？只是人们习惯了它吗？就像，你认为那是怎么回事？嗯，从我的角度来看，凯文·赖利不确定他是否会续订第二季。在那一年的前期准备之前有很多戏剧性事件，我不知道这是否，我想这在某些地方是众所周知的，
we went through and looked at a ton of pictures and we found some from the pilot and things like that. But I actually found pictures from that bar that we all went to. Yeah. And I remember thinking, well, that was such a fun experience. It was completely worth it.
但公司，嗯，有点降低了预算，剥夺了每个人的奖金。而且，你知道，他们确实做了很多紧缩政策来带回我们。我必须在凯文同意下一季之前向他推销一个新的方向。这实际上确实回到了《山丘之王》，因为我在《山丘之王》所做的是说，OK，汉克身上有很多不可爱的方面，但我会建立所有这些可爱的特征来撤销任何人的疑虑。
It didn't need, it doesn't need to be successful for me to have found happiness in shooting that pilot and meeting everybody and it was super good. And I remember also saying something similar at the end of season one. I was like, all right, this will probably tank. You know? And.
比如如果他有时看起来有点厌女，那么我会让他超级支持他的妻子，而且，你知道，当涉及到住在一起的侄女时，是一个完全的男童子军道学家，而且，你知道，各种各样的事情。所以走进它的时候，我就想，好吧，我非常、非常热爱原来的英国节目，所以我们在第一季没有对迈克尔的角色做太多的改动。所以我当时想，我想我知道我我我知道我需要做什么。我需要做和汉克一样的事情。
Our six episodes of season one. Yeah. Our very short season one. But, you know, it was very exciting in season two because it just kept going up and up and up in season two. And by the end of season two, I think, like on Casino Night, we were kind of a successful show by then, I think. What do you attribute that to in season two?
我有一个不同的事情清单，可以挽回迈克尔的角色在观众眼中的形象，它们成为了前六或八集，所以《邓迪奖》的情感剧情是，你知道，员工被迈克尔激怒了，但如果员工之外的某人批评他，他们会保护他。所以那有点像家庭动态的事情，它解决了问题，他是真的被他的员工讨厌吗？
Do you think it's changes we made? Was it just people getting used to it? Like, what do you think it's changes we made? Was it just people getting used to it? What do you think it was? Well, from my perspective, Kevin Riley wasn't sure he was gonna pick up season two. And there was a lot of drama before the up-fronts for that year where, I don't know if this is, I think this is known in some places,
不，他不是。他，你知道，他们对他有一种家庭的感觉。然后有，《游轮》是，从我推销时用的原始餐巾纸，凯文·赖利是，让迈克尔给某人一些非常好的建议，这是观众真的希望他说的。所以当迈克尔告诉吉姆，永远不要放弃，
but the company, um, kind of lowered the budget and stripped everybody's bonuses out. And, you know, they really did a lot of belt tightening to bring us back. And I had to go pitch a new direction to Kevin before he would green light the next season. And this actually does go back a little bit to King of the Hill again, because what I had done at King of the Hill was say, okay, Hank has a lot of unlikable aspects to him, but I'm going to build all these likable features to him to undo whatever anybody's misgivings might be.
那正是观众想要的，某人告诉吉姆。而且，你知道，所以迈克尔有那种洞察力的想法对迈克尔有好处。而且在《政变》中，他实际上在销售方面相当不错。所以他不是一个完全无能的人。这个想法是有一种叫彼得原理的东西。你知道吗？
Like if he maybe appears a little misogynistic at times, then I'm going to make him super supportive of his wife and also, you know, a complete Boy Scout prude when it comes to his niece that's living with them and, you know, various things like that. So going into it, I was like, all right, I was very, very so much in love with the original British show that we didn't make too many changes to Michael's character in the first season. So I was kind of like, I think I know what I I know what I need to do. I need to do the same thing I did with Hank.
是的。是的。是的。所以这个想法是他实际上作为一个销售经理非常好。他只是不应该被变成总经理或分部经理。所以，你知道，像那样不同的事情。我有六或八个事情，我想这会在赛季过程中修复他的角色。所以从我的角度来看，很多是这些事情在削弱
And I had a list of different things that would rehabilitate Michael's character in the eyes of the audience and they became maybe the first six or eight episodes so the emotional plot of the Dundies is you know the staff is very irritated by Michael but if somebody outside the staff criticizes him, they'll defend him. And so that's sort of like a family dynamic kind of thing where it solves the problem of, is he really hated by his staff?
无论问题是什么，有点像制作迈克尔的一个新版本，在那里他更像一个，你知道，令人恼火的叔叔而不是像一个邪恶的老板之类的。一个混蛋老板，是的。我喜欢听到你为角色规划情感剧情的过程。那些是我总是觉得如此迷人的东西。你在剧集中对多个角色这样做过吗？
No, he's not. He's, you know, they have some sort of family feeling towards him. And then there was, Boos Cruise was, from my initial napkin that I went into pitch, Kevin Reilly was, let Michael give some really good advice to somebody that the audience really wants him to say. So when Michael tells Jim, never give up,
你知道他们的情感剧情是什么，还是你在制定那个图表？哦是的，那是编剧室的重要部分。是的。是的。而且对帕姆来说，例如，一件大事是OK，帕姆发生了什么，帕姆和吉姆在一起的障碍是什么，对吗？所以剧集开始了，障碍是罗伊，她订婚了，然后你知道他抓住他的机会，她还没准备好和罗伊分手或作弊之类的。
that's exactly what the audience wanted, somebody to tell Jim. And, you know, so the idea that Michael has that insight is good for Michael. And in the coup, he's actually pretty good at sales. So he's not a total incompetent. The idea was there's something called the Peter Principle. Do you know that?
所以她拒绝了他，然后吉姆去了康涅狄格州。当他回来时，他有一个新女朋友，从他的角度来看这没问题，因为他被拒绝了。帕姆正在看着他和凯伦，你知道，那一季后半段的大障碍有点像是帕姆的自信水平，她是否获得了说出她想要的勇气。而在《海滩游戏》中，当她走过煤炭时，那是一个像一年准备的时刻，因为它让她感觉足够。
Yes. Yes. Yes. So the idea was he was actually really good as a sales manager. He just shouldn't have been turned into the general manager or the branch manager. So, you know, the different things like that. I had maybe six or eight things that I thought would fix his character over the course of the season. So from my perspective, a lot of it is these things were chipping away at
受鼓舞。是的。是的。我喜欢那个。太好了。有很多那种东西。是的。
whatever the problems were and kind of making a new version of Michael where he was more of a, you know, exasperating uncle than like a evil boss or something. A jerky boss, yeah. I love hearing about that process of you laying out the emotional plot for a character. That's the stuff I always find so fascinating. Did you do that with multiple characters on the show?
而且，我的写作倾向是有一个经过极其精雕细琢的情感故事，但这是我所谓的在水下，只有在剧中的一个时刻浮出水面来完成它的工作，然后又消失在水下。但你必须把那个潜艇放在正确的地方。你必须在它不被观众注意时规划它的路径
Did you know what their emotional plot was or were you charting that? Oh yeah, that's a huge part of the writer's room. Yeah. Yeah. And one of the big things with Pam for instance is okay what's going on with Pam, what are the obstacles to Pam and Jim getting together right? So the show starts and the obstacles Roy and she's engaged and then you know he takes his his shot and and she's not ready to break up with Roy or to cheat or anything.
贯穿整集。小时刻，是的。所以对我来说，做重写的一个问题是有时你忘记了，因为你只是看着剧情的表面，你忘记了其中一些台词也在为潜艇绘制航线，而且你知道你就像我得到了一个更好的笑话，你把笑话换成了一些对表面剧情有效但对
So she turns him down and then Jim goes to Connecticut. And by the time he comes back, he has a new girlfriend, which from his perspective is okay because he was turned down. And Pam is watching him with Karen and, you know, the big obstacle at the second half of that season was sort of Pam's confidence level and does she get the courage to say what she wants. And in beach games, when she walks across the coals, that's a moment that was like a year in preparation because it's getting her to feel enough.
潜艇到达它需要去的地方没有帮助的事情。所以你一直在平衡表面故事和那种躺在下面一点点的心脏故事。是的，在《山丘之王》之前，我有在其他节目工作的经验，他们对情感剧情不太认真，当时的很多喜剧作家有一个术语
Emboldened. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Love that. So good. There's a lot of that kind of stuff. Yeah.
叫糖蜜切割机，这个想法是，在剧集结束时，会有一点糖蜜，那是一些小块的，像，aw，拥抱，然后他们需要在那个之后有一个笑话叫糖蜜切割机，因为他们太厌恶他们刚刚，你知道，刚刚做了一些糖蜜的事情。我就想，好吧，如果它不是糖蜜，你不必感到尴尬，你知道，如果它真的有效
And then my writing predilection is to have an emotional story that is extremely well worked out, but is what I would call underwater, and only surfaces at one moment in the show to do its job, and then disappears underwater again. But you have to get that submarine at the right place. You have to plot its path all the way when it's not noticed by the audience
而且你真的感觉到了什么，那么你不需要一个小糖蜜切割机，如果它不是糖蜜，你不必感到尴尬，你知道，如果它真的有效，而且你真的感觉到了什么，那么你不需要一个小糖蜜切割机，你知道吗？但这需要很多未被赞赏的努力把所有那些小节拍放进去。也有很多好的吉姆和帕姆的，当你重温它的时候。我最喜欢的一个是当他们就在
all the way through the episode. Little moments, yeah. And so one of the problems with, for me, doing rewrites is sometimes you forget, because you're just looking at the surface of the plot, you're forgetting that some of these lines are also charting a course for the submarine and you know you you're like I got a better joke and you switch the joke to something else that works for the surface plot but doesn't help the
一天结束时听语音邮件。那是我最喜欢的之一。是的。所以就像，我认为《商学院》可能是我最喜欢的一集，但我认为那一集是一个伟大的帕姆和迈克尔时刻。是的，是的。在艺术展上。
submarine get where it needs to go. So you're constantly balancing the sort of surface story with like the heart story that's lying underneath a little bit. Yeah, before King of the Hill, I had the experience of working on other shows where they didn't take the emotional storyline very seriously and a lot of the comedy writers at that time had a term which they used
是的，在艺术展上，当他是唯一一个对她的艺术真正充满热情的人时。是的，他是那个出现的人。他也是唯一知道Sprinkles的人，就像，对她的艺术感到热情的人。是的。他是那个出现的人。他也是唯一知道Sprinkles的人，就像，对Sprinkles感到不安的人。我刚看了那个。是的。
called treacle cutter and the idea was that at the end of an episode there'd be called treacle cutter. And the idea was that at the end of an episode, there'd be some treacle that was some little piece of, like, awe, hug, and then that they needed to have a joke after that called the treacle cutter, because they were so disgusted that they had just, you know, just done some sort of treacle. And I was like, well, you don't have to be embarrassed if it isn't treacle, you know, if it actually works
是的，在《趣味跑》里。是的。是的。他确实在一秒钟后把名字弄错了。他弄对了。他第一次就弄对了。他确实。然后他又回到了迈克尔。
and you actually feel something, then you don't need a little treacle cutter, you don't have to be embarrassed if it isn't treacle, you know, if it actually works, and you actually feel something, then you don't need a little treacle cutter, you know? But it's a lot of underappreciated effort to put all those little beats in. There's so many good Jim and Pam ones, too, when you re-watch it. One of my favorites is when they're just
但他真的转过身说，哦，不。他就像，他为她心碎了。是的。墙上有任何剧情或卡片是你没能做但你仍然希望的吗？我们有那个完整的宠物日剧本。我们有一个完整的剧本没能变得漂亮。你能稍微分享一下那个剧本的故事是关于什么的吗？是的，所以我们有，我想，那会是第一季，对吧？所以我想我们只有五集的预算，但我们有六集的剧本预算。
listening to the voicemails at the end of the day. That was one of my favorites. Yeah. So like, I think Business School is possibly my favorite episode, but I think that one is such a great Pam Michael moment. Yeah, yeah. At the art show.
所以我写了一个额外的剧集叫《宠物日》，迈克尔鼓励每个人带他们的宠物进来。而且我想德怀特带进了一个半狼。而且，你知道，有一个——总之，在一天结束时，我就想，我要确保所有的作家都得到一个剧本，我会拿走那个并把它搁置，也许它以后会回来。它从来没回来过。所以——我必须想象如果你是肯特·苏博纳克，你被交给了《宠物日》，他只会想，我怎么——因为我确实记得
Yeah, at the art show, when he's the only one who is really enthusiastic about her art. Yeah, he's the one that showed up. He's also the only person that knew Sprinkles, like, who got enthusiastic about her art. Yeah. He's the one that showed up. He's also the only person that knew Sprinkles, like, who got upset about Sprinkles. I just watched that. Yeah.
剧本。我怎么得到这个半狼？但然后还有，像，有一只鸟在里面。这将是片场有很多动物。是的。我想很多人可能会说不可制作。我希望安吉拉有13只猫在那里。我得回去看看那个剧本。我知道她有猫。你知道谁几乎知道安吉拉·马丁的每一只猫吗？是比莉·艾利什。
Yeah, in Fun Run. Yeah. Yeah. He did get the name wrong a second later. He got it right. He got it right the first time. He did. And then he was back to Michael.
是的，她是忠实粉丝。她来了节目，我们和她玩了一个办公室琐事游戏。而且我的意思是，我努力命名它们所有，而她做到了。我就想，哇，那太神奇了。有什么名人是你见过的，他们一直不停地谈论《办公室》，这让你感到惊讶吗？好吧，我喜欢你的前提是我在见到
But he literally turned and goes, oh, no. He's like, he was heartbroken for her. Yeah. Is there any storyline or card that was on the wall that you didn't get to do that you still wish? We have that whole pet day script. We have a whole script that didn't get pretty. Can you share a little bit about what that script's story was all about? Yeah, so we had, I think, it would have been season one, right? So I think we had only enough budget for five episodes, but we had enough script budget for six.
很多名人。在我们的心目中，你在所有的豪华派对上。你在外面，闲聊。是的，不，不。我的意思是，我在某处听说斯皮尔伯格真的很喜欢这部剧。就像，他会是一个大……什么？什么？这是我们的新闻。他对我来说会是一个大名人。哦天哪。
So I wrote an extra episode called Pet Day, where Michael encourages everybody to bring their pets in. And I think Dwight brought in a Demi-Wolf. And, you know, there's a – anyway, at the end of the day, I was like, I'm going to make sure all the writers get a script and I'll take that one and shelve it and maybe it'll come back later. And it never came back later. So – I have to imagine if you were Kent Subornak and you got handed Pet Day, he was just like, how am I – Because I do remember
所以那很好。珍娜有一个好的。讲那个故事。关于安吉丽娜·朱莉？是的，讲出来。是的，我在一个派对上，安吉丽娜·朱莉带着她的几个孩子在那里，我看到了她，我注意到就像我的余光里，她正直接朝我走来，我就想谁在我后面？她走近谁？她直接走到我面前自我介绍。她说，嗨，我的名字是安吉，我只是想告诉你我的家人，我们是《办公室》的忠实粉丝。然后你就想，没有签名。我知道，我就想，离开这儿。
the script. How do I get this Demi-Wolf? But then also there were like, there was a bird that was in it. And this was going to be a lot of animals on set. Yeah. I think a lot of people would probably have said unproducible. I hope Angela had 13 of her cats there. I got to go back and look at that script. I know she had 13 of her cats there. I gotta go back and look at that script. I know she had cats. You know who knew almost every single of Angela Martin's cats? Was Billie Eilish.
她非常好且温暖，我就想，什么？她说，我和我的孩子们在这儿，我们一起看它，他们是忠实粉丝。你不介意跟他们打个招呼吗？我说，是的。我走过去和他们所有人谈话，她非常好。她——我说是的。我走过去和他们所有人谈话，她非常好。她非常好。她就像，哦，我们应该找个时间一起吃午饭，或者我们应该。然后我就
Yes, she's a huge fan. She came on the show, we played an office trivia game with her. And I mean, I was struggling to name them all and she got them. I was like, wow, that's amazing. Are there any celebrities that you've met that have just gone on and on and on about The Office that maybe surprised you? Well, I love that your premise is that I'm meeting
像，是的，当然我们应该。但后来我像，我不知道怎么跟进那个。是的。那是真正的一起吃午饭，还是就像派对闲聊？她说了两次。OK。那你应该得到她的信息。但也曾经有一次迈克尔·道格拉斯提供给我……他在西班牙的房子。他在西班牙度假的房子，因为我和他拍了一部电影。他在两天内说了三次。
a lot of celebrities. You're in all the fancy parties in our mind. You're out there, hobnobbing. Yeah, no, no. I mean, I heard somewhere that Spielberg really liked the show. Like, he would be a big... What? What? This is news to us. He'd be a big celebrity to me. Oh my gosh.
所以就像第一天他说了两次。他就像，哦，凯瑟琳和我在西班牙有一栋房子。你可以使用它。第二天，当李去探望时，他说，珍娜告诉过你我们在西班牙的地方吗？你们两个欢迎使用它。哇。然而，我还没有在他在西班牙的房子度假。
So that's good. Jenna has a good one. Tell the story. About Angelina Jolie? Yes, tell it. Yeah, I was at a party and Angelina Jolie was there with a few of her kids and I clocked her and I noticed like out of my peripheral vision that she was walking right toward me and I was like who's behind me? Who's she walking to? And she came right up to me and introduced herself. She said, Hi, my name's Angie and I just wanted to tell you my family, we are such a huge fan of the office. And you're like, no autographs. I know, I was like, get out of here.
我只是，我不知道怎么。你怎么过渡那个？是的，我怎么让那个发生？我会跟进那个的。而且，也许如果你只是在西班牙有房子之类的，你对它非常大方。也许你只是像，去我在摩纳哥的房子。我不知道。也许有税收原因。就像……看看你，你太愤世嫉俗了。你就像，对迈克尔有什么好处？我可以把它注销。OK，我有一个问题，既然我们在回顾20年。我们
She was so nice and warm and I was like, what? And she said, I'm here with my kids and we watch it together and they're huge fans. Would you mind saying hello to them? And I said, yes. And I walked over and talked to them all and she was so nice. She I said yes. And I walked over and talked to them all and she was so nice. She was so nice. She was like, oh, we should get lunch sometime or we should. And I was
一直在辩论是否要包含这个问题，我们被它逗乐了，所以把它当回事。有什么剧情或剧集你认为回顾时我们可能跳过鲨鱼了吗？哦天哪。我们差点跳过尼亚加拉瀑布。是的。但我们没跳。我们知道的。那可能就是那一刻。
like, yes, of course we should. But then I'm like, I don't know how to follow up on that. Yeah. Is that like a real let's have lunch or is that kind of like party chit chat? She said it twice. Okay. Then you should have gotten her information. But also one time Michael Douglas offered me... His house in Spain. His house in Spain to vacation at because I did a movie with him. He said it three times on two different days.
我们非常接近。是的。男孩。好吧，我的意思是，跳过鲨鱼的概念，对我来说就像有一条分界线，节目是好的，然后节目有点俗气。对。哦，而且我认为那不是我对问题的意图。是的，不，不。我想更像是有一个时刻或决定让你觉得，是的，如果
So like the first day he said it twice. He's like, oh, Catherine and I have a house in Spain. You can use it. And the next day, when Lee was visiting, he said, did Jenna tell you about our place in Spain? You two are welcome to use it. Wow. And yet, I have not vacationed at his house in Spain.
我要重来一次，我不会走那条路。我对节目感到非常自豪。我不会对节目。我不会，我不会去那里。而且我认为有，我在《山丘之王》上学到，我非常担心，我们有一集，而且我知道我一直在《办公室女士》播客上谈论《山丘之王》，但我们有一集他们，汉克和他的朋友们都变成了志愿消防员，他们就像三个臭皮匠去了一个消防站，我完全在出汗
I just, I don't know how to. How do you transition that? Yeah, how do I make that happen? I would have followed up on that. Also, maybe if you just have houses in Spain and whatnot, you're very gracious about it. Maybe you're just like, go to my house in Monaco. I don't know. Maybe there's a tax reason. It's like... Look at you, you're so cynical. You're like, what's in it for Michael? I can write it off. Okay, I have a question since we're reflecting on 20 years. We were
因为那一集没有地下情感故事，全是傻瓜东西，我就想，好吧，就是那个，我们破坏了节目，然后一大堆人就说，那是我最喜欢的一集。我就想，哦，OK，它只是一个不同的，它只是，你知道，稍微不同的齿轮。是的。而且一旦你确定了你的主要齿轮是什么，做一些更广泛或更奇怪的事情是很有趣的，因为总会有一些人那是
debating about including this question and we got tickled about it, so just take it with a grain of salt. Is there a storyline or episode that you think we maybe jumped the shark with when you look back? Oh my goodness. We almost jumped a horse over Niagara Falls. Yes. But we didn't. That we know. That could have been the moment.
突出的。好吧，你正坐在两个热爱这部剧并认为它完美的人对面。所以。你的，是的，让我们问，你一直在做深度重温，我们哪里出错了？有一集我会移除。我感觉坏说它。
We came very close. Yeah. Boy. Well, I mean, the notion of jump the shark, for me, is like there's a dividing line between the show was good and then the show was kind of cheesy. Right. Oh, and I think that's not my intention with the question. Yeah, no, no. I think it's more like was there a moment or a decision where you're like, yeah, if
它是我们被迫做的片段秀。记得那集吗？它是像，我甚至不知道你是否称它为一集。它叫《银行家》。是的。感觉像。它是像，我甚至不知道你是否称它为一集。它叫《银行家》。它感觉像一个环绕。它感觉像几分钟的环绕。它就像一个环绕。它就像几分钟的环绕。NBC让我们做。这是我的感受。是的。所以我对那个的背景故事不记得了。它不。嗯，而且情况是，那部分是原始的，当这个银行家进来
I had it to do all over again, I wouldn't have gone down that road. I'm pretty proud of the show. I'm not going of the show. I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna go there. And also I think that there's, I learned on King of the Hill, I was very worried about, we had an episode where, and I know I've been talking a lot about King of the Hill on this Office Ladies podcast, but we had an episode where they, all of Hank and his friends became volunteer firemen and they were just like the three stooges go to a firehouse and I was completely sweating it
去……哦，而且他太棒了，扮演银行家的人。是的，他是个伟大的演员。而且他和托比有一些场景，然后证明了所有闪回的合理性。所有那些东西都很棒。这是一集有趣的前提，就是这家保险银行，对吧，他不得不进来，他就像，你有什么人力资源问题吗？就像这个想法，托比，谁知道办公室的所有问题，不得不有点保护办公室？
because there was no subterranean emotional story on that one, it was just all goofball stuff and I was like, well, that was it, we broke the show and then a whole bunch of people were like, that's my favorite episode. And I was like, oh, okay, it's just a different, it's just, you know, slightly different gear. Yeah. And once you have established what your main gear is, it's kind of fun to do something a little broader or a little weirder or something, because there's going to be some people who that's the
我本来希望整集都是那样，但相反我们不得不继续去看所有这些片段。所以我认为它没有，那是那一集，很难说它是《办公室》的一集。但是……是的，它对我来说几乎没有注册。我甚至不记得它真的。对。
standout. Well, you're sitting across from two people who love the show and think it's perfect. So. What would your, yeah, let's ask, you've been doing the in-depth rewatch, where did we go wrong? There's one episode that I would remove. I feel bad saying it.
但我认为除此之外，在看所有剧集时，我不认为我们曾经跳过鲨鱼。我不认为有，我认为我们确实只是有不同的齿轮。然后在重温节目时，当我们到达那些有不同齿轮的剧集之一时，我对此感到兴奋。是的。
It's our clip show that we were forced to do. Remember that episode? It's like, I don't even know if you call it an episode. It was called The Banker. Yeah. It felt like. It's like I don't even know if you call it an episode. It was called The Banker. It felt like a wrap around. It felt like a couple minutes of a wrap around. It was like a wrap around. It was like a couple minutes of a wrap around. NBC made us do. It was what I'm feeling. Yeah. So I don't remember the backstory on that. It doesn't. Well, and the thing is, is that the part that was original where this banker comes in
而且再次，人们会出现，他们会，你知道，他们会喜欢那种东西。而且关于节目的另一件事是，因为冷开场和因为子情节，对我来说，有令人难忘的时刻，我不知道它们在哪一集。是的。像跑酷，冷开场。就像，我不知道它们在哪一集。你知道吗，像，跑酷，冷开场。
to... Oh, and he's fantastic, the guy that played the banker. Yeah, he's a great actor. And he has some scenes with Toby that then justify all of the flashing back. All that stuff is great. It was an interesting premise for an episode, which is that this insurance bank, right, he had to come in and he's like, do you have any HR problems? Like this idea that Toby, who knows everything wrong with the office, is having to kind of protect the office?
就像，我不知道那在哪一集，那在哪一季。它只是太棒了，你知道，素描喜剧。我们有这么棒的冷开场。而且你知道，我们现在也在看网络剧集。而且网络剧集很棒。我只是喜欢学习关于角色的新东西，但那听起来是真的，但也许你只是还没
I would have loved for the whole episode to be that, but instead we had to keep going to all these clips. So I think it doesn't, that is the one that, it's hard to even say it was an episode of The Office. But... Yeah, it almost doesn't register for me. I don't even remember it really. Right.
看过它们那么多。甚至有这个非常有趣的一个，盖博是如此令人难以置信的嫉妒，奥斯卡在萨布雷页面上有一个乔·班内特喜欢的博客，而盖博只是垂涎乔·班内特的青睐。所以他试图开始一个播客播客，它只是让我裂开了。你知道什么如此疯狂吗？我不能，我忘了她的名字是乔·班内特，我现在正在和乔·班内特，动画师工作。他做了一个节目叫《常见副作用》
But I think otherwise, in watching all the episodes, I don't think we ever jumped the shark. I don't think that there's, I think we did just have different gears. And then in re-watching the show, when we get to one of those episodes with a different gear, I am excited about it. Yeah.
和办公室作家史蒂夫·希利。他们俩为我与迈克·贾奇一起做的动画公司创作了它。所以我已经和乔·班内特工作并谈话了很长时间。我忘了。当我提到它时，你的脸上确实有一个有趣的表情。OK，我有另一个问题要问你。如果你是剧中的一个角色，格雷格，哪个角色？我是剧中的一个角色，我是迈克尔的邻居。我知道。你是纱线推销员。
And again, people will come up and they'll, you know, they'll love that kind of stuff. And the other thing about the show is, because of the cold opens and because of the subplots, for me, there's memorable moments that I have no idea what episode they're in. Yeah. Like parkour, cold open. Like, I don't know what episode they're in. You know, like, Parkour, Cold Open.
你是纱线推销员，我们喜欢它。所以如果你不是住在迈克尔公寓隔壁的纱线推销员，你会最认同谁，你会是哪个主要演员角色？哦，好吧，听着，你知道，我不打算假装我有成为节目明星的必要魅力，但作为一个人，在办公室的社交世界中是老板，并且以前是我做的前一个节目的老板，我倾向于认同老板问题和
Like, I don't know what episode that's in, what season that's in. It's just such a great, you know, sketch comedy. We had such great Cold Opens. And you know, we're watching the webisodes now as well. And the webisodes are great. I just love learning new things about characters, but that ring true, but maybe you just haven't
人们与迈克尔互动的方式。所以例如，迈克尔必须在万圣节解雇某人但仍然想和他们做朋友的那一集。你知道我的意思吗？就像，那是一个真正老板观点的一种剧情。而且你知道，也只是史蒂夫和我的年纪差不多。所以就像这个想法，你知道，他超级进入，我想让你振作起来，你知道，所有这些东西都像是，你知道，对于那个年龄段的人来说完全正确。所以我可能会认同迈克尔。这一集是由三星Galaxy带给你的。
seen them as much. Even there was this very funny one where Gabe is so incredibly jealous that Oscar has a blog on the Sabre page that Joe Bennett loves, and Gabe just covets Joe Bennett's favor. So he tries to start a podcast podcast and it just cracked me up. You know what's so crazy? I can't, I forgot her name was Joe Bennett and I'm working with Joe Bennett, the animator now. He does a show called Common Side Effects
曾经捕捉到一个很棒的夜晚视频，结果被那个吵闹的说话者毁了吗？有了新款三星Galaxy S25 Ultra上的音频擦除，你可以减少或移除不需要的噪音，并重温你最喜欢的时刻而没有干扰。而且不仅如此。像NowBrief这样的新Galaxy AI功能会根据你的日程安排给你个性化的洞察，这样无论发生什么你都做好了准备。现在就在Samsung.com购买三星Galaxy S25 Ultra。暂停你正在听的任何东西，点击播放你的下一次冒险。住两晚并获得50美元的Best Western礼品卡。生活就是旅行。充分利用它
with office writer Steve Healy. The two of them created it for the animation company that I do with Mike Judge. And so I've been working with and talking to Joe Bennett for such a long time. I forgot. You did have a funny expression on your face when I was mentioning it. All right I have another question for you. If you were a character on the show, Greg, which character? I am a character on the show, I'm Michael's neighbor. I know. You're the yarn salesman.
在Best Western。访问BestWestern.com获取完整的条款和条件。在Desjardins，我们说商业。我们说设备现代化。我们精通条款和条件。所以加入已经指望我们的超过40万名加拿大企业家，今天联系Desjardins。我们很乐意谈论商业。音乐格雷格，我很好奇。我们从来没有在斯克兰顿拍过一集，而且我认为那是一件成本问题。是的，我们试过了。
You're the yarn salesman, we loved it. So if you weren't the yarn salesman that lives next to Michael in the condo, who would you identify most with and what main cast character would you be? Oh, well, look, you know, I'm not going to pretend that I have the necessary charisma to be the star of the show but as somebody who in the in the social world of the office was the boss and was previously the boss on the prior show that I did, I tend to identify with boss problems and
是的。肯定有所有这些伟大的计划去那里拍摄。关于斯克兰顿奇怪的事情是，它以一种全景城市难以与之匹敌的方式非常美丽，因为那里到处都是美丽的树木，斯克兰顿周围到处都是。而且有那个湖。它真的漂亮。是的，而且你知道，它在1800年代是一件大事。所以市中心的建筑就像这些很酷的石头建筑，它只是有像很多美丽和特征，我们低估了它。但我确实试图在那里拍摄，部分原因是由于在赛季开始时使用斯克兰顿或类似的事情的困难。
the way people interact with Michael. So for instance, the episode where Michael has to fire someone on Halloween but still wants to be friends with them. You know what I mean? Like, that's a real boss point of view kind of a storyline. And you know, just sort of also Steve and I are pretty much the same age. And so like the idea that, you know, he's super into, I want to pump you up, you know, all these things that are like, you know, hit exactly right for somebody of that age group. So I would probably identify with Michael. This episode is brought to you by Samsung Galaxy.
它就像，你不能把它放在赛季中间，因为它只会吹爆整个计划。所以它要么必须在最开始要么在最后。而且我不知道，它只是逃过了我们。《公园与游憩》去了英国拍摄一季，做那件事的唯一方式是把它像赛季拍摄的前三天在英国，然后你知道我们会稍后加进去。好吧就像
Ever captured a great night video only for it to be ruined by that one noisy talker? With audio erase on the new Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra, you can reduce or remove unwanted noise and relive your favorite moments without the distractions. And that's not all. New Galaxy AI features like NowBrief will give you personalized insights based on your day schedule so that you're prepared no matter what. Buy the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra now at Samsung.com. Hit pause on whatever you're listening to and hit play on your next adventure. Stay two nights and get a $50 Best Western gift card. Life's the trip. Make the most of it
我说我一直在和我的家人看《摩登家庭》。他们去夏威夷？他们确实去过夏威夷。是的。他们我相信，他们去过澳大利亚。他们去很多地方。嘿，我们去了长滩和……好吧，你得去尼亚加拉。我得去尼亚加拉。那实际上真的很酷。我的意思是，那是，我不知道我是否会去
at Best Western. Visit BestWestern.com for complete terms and conditions. At Desjardins, we speak business. We speak equipment modernization. We're fluent in terms and conditions. So join the more than 400,000 Canadian entrepreneurs who already count on us and contact Desjardins today. We'd love to talk business. Music Greg, I'm curious. We never shot an episode in Scranton, and I think it was a cost thing. Yeah, we tried.
尼亚加拉瀑布否则在我的一生中。而且它是世界奇迹之一。所以那相当酷。史蒂夫去了纽约，就像小规模剧组。是的，那超级有趣。我当时在面包车里。那是一件疯狂的事情，因为我们的许可证，你知道，我们不像一部电影，我们会封锁街道并让所有这些临时演员进来假装成真正的纽约人。我们在两辆面包车里，基本上面包车会开到时代广场。
Yeah. Definitely had all these great plans to go shoot there. The weird thing about Scranton is it's remarkably beautiful in a way that Panorama City has trouble you know measuring up to it because there's beautiful trees all beautiful all around Scranton. And there's that lake. It's really pretty. Yeah, and you know, it was a big deal in the 1800s. So the buildings in the downtown are like these cool stone buildings and it's just got like a lot of beauty and character that we shortchanged it. But I did try to shoot there and part of it is the difficulty of starting the season with Scranton or something like that.
史蒂夫会跳出来，兰德尔会带着相机跳出来。我想我导演了那一集。所以我当时在那里。就像游击队风格。而且它会是游击队风格，直到有人去，它是40岁的老处女。然后突然，
It was like, you couldn't put it in the middle of the season because it would just blow the whole schedule up. And so it either had to be at the very beginning or the very end. And I don't know, it just escaped us. Parks and Rec went to England to shoot one season and the only way to do that was to put it like the first three days of shooting for the season were in England and then you know we'd get like salted in later. Well like
因为它在电影出来后就在那儿，人群会开始挤在我们身上。我们会想，好吧，我们得到了我们得到的。然后我们会跳回面包车，我们去其他地方。那是非常令人兴奋的拍摄。我之后一直告诉制片经理，无论它处于什么情况，我都会想，为什么我们不能只是跳进面包车然后去拍摄它？是的，像纽约。
I said I've been watching Modern Family with my family. They go to Hawaii? They have gone to Hawaii. Yeah. They I believe, they've gone to Australia. They're going a lot of places. Hey, we went to Long Beach and... Well, you got to go to Niagara. I got to go to Niagara. And that was actually really cool. I mean, that was, I don't know if I would have gone
是的。是的。而且只是跳出来真的很快。是的。好吧，我记得有一年，因为圣帕特里克节游行在斯克兰顿太有名了，总是有很多讨论关于我们将那个游行纳入一集。有太多的推销关于某人在游行中或者是无论它是什么。
to Niagara Falls otherwise in my life. And it's one of the wonders of the world. So that was pretty cool. And Steve went to New York, like with the skeleton crew. Yes, that was super fun. I was in the van for that. That was a crazy thing because our permits, you know, we didn't, we weren't like a movie where we would shut down the street and get all these extras to come in and pretend to be real New Yorkers. We were in two vans and basically a van would roll up to Times Square.
而且我记得有一年，格雷格，你告诉我，你说，我想我们要做了。问题是，你知道，我们不能拍摄真正的游行，因为那样剧集会在圣帕特里克节之后出来。所以如果我们想成为一样……是的，我们得像在八月拍它或者……而且你告诉我斯克兰顿同意为我们把他们的游行搬到八月，我就想整个城市将为我们做一个假游行？那太神奇了。城市超级酷。是的。而且实际上我仍然和蒂姆·霍尔姆斯和米歇尔·邓普西保持联系。哦是的。记得他们吗？当然。而且他们即将在Everhart博物馆有一个20周年展览。
Steve would jump out, Randall would jump out with the camera. And I think I directed that episode. And so I was out there. Just sort of gorilla style. And it would be gorilla style until somebody went, it's a 40 year old virgin. And then suddenly,
哦，那太棒了。博物馆在斯克兰顿。我们将在我们的Instagram动态中分享那个。是的，我不确定它确切什么时候发生，但它即将来临。我知道我们一直在试图让道具之类的东西被送到那里。他们会有什么在那里？他们得到物品了吗？你知道吗？是的，我让他们和NBC道具存储组联系。就像办公桌之类的？好吧，很多那些东西被卖了。哦对，那是真的，那是真的。我确实听到了那个。我想你告诉过我们。是的，不，我当时想，我要，我想保留所有的东西，他们就像，不，不，我们必须为史密森学会保留它。
because it was right after the movie came out, crowds would start to jam in on us. And we'd be like, well, we got what we got. And we'd jump back in the van and we go to someplace else. It was extremely exciting shoot. And I kept telling the line producers afterwards, no matter what situation it was in, I was like, why can't we just jump in a van and go shoot it? Yeah, like New York.
然后我转过身，他们在某个拍卖网站上卖它，好吧，去看看那个展览会很酷，我想上线看看它，但你知道，我有帕姆的办公桌，你见过那个，对吗？我很抱歉等，什么？我要开始哭了，你有我的桌子？我买了你的接待台上线。等，你在拍卖会上买了它？我在拍卖会上买了它，是的。它在我的办公室里。不可能。格雷格，我们可以来看它吗？
Yeah. Yeah. And just hop Like New York. Yeah. Yeah. And just hop out really quick. Yeah. Well, I remember one year, because the St. Patrick's Day Parade is so famous in Scranton, there was always a lot of talk about us incorporating that parade into an episode. There were so many pitches about someone being in the parade or whatever it was.
你的办公室接待台？不，它只是某种程度上像是在它自己的一个区域，上面有一个小牌子。你必须去坐它，珍娜。我不知道你是否想去坐它。我不知道。它太奇怪了，它脱离了背景。我不知道你是否想去坐它。我不知道。它脱离了背景。
And I remember one year, Greg, you told me, you said, I think we're going to do it. The problem is that, you know, we can't shoot the real parade because then the episode will come out after St. Patrick's Day. So if we wanted to be the same... Yeah, we'd have to shoot it like in August or something or... And you told me that Scranton agreed to move their parade to August for us and I was like the whole city is gonna make a fake parade for us? That's pretty amazing. The city is super cool. Yeah. And actually I'm still in touch with Tim Holmes and Michelle Dempsey. Oh yeah. Remember them? Of course. And they're having a 20th anniversary exhibit in the Everhart Museum coming up.
我不知道，哦天哪，我不知道那在情感上会是什么。是的，它极其沉重。我正在考虑把它送到Everhart博物馆参加这个展览。你必须把它运送就像在卡车上之类的。它可能会散架。我不知道，我担心。它是一个真正时髦的高度。所以很难把我的腿放在下面。有一个架子在，某种程度上一个尴尬的地方
Oh, that's fantastic. Museum in Scranton. We'll share that in our Instagram stories. Yeah, I'm not sure exactly when it's happening, but it's coming up soon. I know we've been trying to get props and stuff to be sent out there. What are they going to have there? Have they gotten items? Do you know? Yeah, I put them in touch with the NBC prop storage group. Like the desks and stuff? Well, a lot of that stuff was sold. Oh right, that's right, that's right. I did hear that. You told us that I think. Yeah, no, I was like, I'm gonna, I want to hang on to all of the stuff and they were like, no, no, we have to save it for the Smithsonian.
在它的后面。确实有，而且它也非常窄。就像它不深。所以它只有键盘那么深。所以如果我曾经不得不假装就像我在写什么东西，没有地方写它或者我不得不就像移动键盘。好吧我认为它它某种程度上就像为两个层面制造的对吧？就像如果你想输入，你有一个键盘在架子上，某种程度上是半路下来，你可以
And then I turned around and they were selling it on some auction place but well it'd be cool to check out that exhibit I want to go online and look at it but you know I have Pam's desk you've seen that right I'm sorry wait what I'm gonna start crying you have my desk I bought your reception desk online. Wait, you bought it in the auction? I bought it in the auction, yeah. It's in my offices. No way. Greg, can we come see it?
就像降低椅子或什么？不，它只是就像有一个办公桌部分，但然后有一个办公桌部分，但然后有上部分，人们会站着，吉姆会把他的手肘休息。是的，完全正确。是的，所以很多时候在剧中，如果我在写一条信息或什么，你看到我在上部分做那个，
The reception desk for your offices? No, it's just sort of like on an area of its own with a little plaque on it. You have to go sit in it, Jenna. I don't know if you wanna go sit in it. I don't know. It's so weird, it's out of context. I don't know if you want to go sit in it. I don't know. It's out of context.
是因为真的几乎没有桌子。好吧，这对摄像机有效。它确实。是的，不，它是一个真正制作精良的，你知道，家具。它非常具有标志性，完美地适合空间，它是不寻常的。我想来看它。是的。我可以报告回来，珍娜，你考虑一下。好吧。我有另一个问题要问你，格雷格。如果你能回去重温你在《办公室》的时间里的一个时刻，那会是什么？
I don't, oh my god, I don't know how that would be emotionally. Yeah, it's extremely heavy. I'm considering sending it to the Everhart Museum for this exhibit. You'd have to ship it like on a big truck or something. It might fall apart. I don't know, I'm worried. It was a real funky height. So it was really hard to get my legs underneath it. There's like a shelf on the, sort of an awkward place
哦天哪。好吧，我不得不说我喜欢，显然，和作家们闲逛，但导演可能最有趣，因为演员和与演员互动。而且我只是，我不知道，第一个浮现在我脑海中的事情是，有时我会导演雷恩做谈话头，我们会咯咯笑，只是，你知道，它会，这是一个超级、超级有趣。
on the back of it. There is, and also it was very narrow. Like it's not deep. So it only was as deep as a keyboard. So if I ever had to pretend like I was writing something down, there was nowhere to write it down or I'd have to like move the keyboard. Well I think it's it's sort of like made for two levels right? Like if you wanted to type, you have a keyboard on a shelf that's sort of halfway down and you can
因为我也认为我不得不说，那雷恩，你知道，那德怀特也是我强烈认同的另一个方面，是那种奇怪的生存主义极客部分，你知道。所以，是的，所以他和我会真的有点进入节奏，进入德怀特的那个方面。是的。在谈话头上。而且有其他角色我不得不，我不能导演。因为某种原因，克里德会，就像，如果我在房间导演，他会崩溃。所以，我会不得不对克里德说，嘿，我超级忙，我得去用卫生间，
like lower the chair or something? No it was just like there was just like a desk portion but then there was just like a desk portion, but then there was the upper portion where people would stand and Jim would rest his elbows. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, so a lot of times in the show, if I'm writing a message or something and you see that I'm doing it on that upper portion,
你只是一直和DP或什么进行，我会走出去，我会听他，这样他可以在没有我盯着他看的情况下做它。我不知道那里的问题是什么。好吧，我非常喜欢花絮，我的孩子们喜欢花絮，所以我看了很多。而且我会说那个打破最多的人
it's because there was really barely any desk. Well, that worked well for camera though. It did. Yeah, no, it was a really well-made you know piece of furniture. It's very iconic, fit the space perfectly, it was unusual. I want to come see it. Yeah. I can report back Jenna, you think on it. All right. I have another question for you Greg. If you could go back and relive a moment from your time on The Office, what would it be?
是雷恩和他的谈话头。是的。他到处都是花絮。他的大脑在材料前面，就像搜索替代品之类的。因为他知道他有能力脱离剧本并做他自己的事情。所以有时他会领先于材料
Oh my goodness. Well, I have to say that I loved, obviously, hanging out with the writers, but directing was the most fun, probably, because of the cast and interacting with the cast. And I just, I don't know, the first thing that popped into my head was there was times when I would direct Rain doing Talking Heads and we would get the giggles and just, you know, it would, it was a super, super fun.
并开始对自己能说什么感到兴奋。他要说什么。他要说什么。他知道这是极其错误的。你知道吗？是的。是的。我们也早些时候谈到了所有试镜。
Cause I also think that I have have to say, that Rain, you know, that Dwight is also another aspect that I identify with strongly, is the kind of weird survivalist nerd part, you know. So, yeah, so he and I would really kind of get into a groove going into that side of Dwight. Yeah. On the talking heads. And there's other characters I had to be, I couldn't direct. Like, for some reason Creed would, like, have a meltdown if I was in the room directing. So, I would have to say to Creed, like, hey, I'm super busy, I gotta go use the bathroom,
我们回去有点为了20周年纪念的荣誉，我们看了所有这些试镜带。因为它们在线。是的。是的，很奇怪，不是吗，它们都在外面？我的意思是。是的，它们不是完整的试镜，你知道，磁带只是小片段。不，我记得。我们不得不得到许可，我想。它们是一个DVD额外内容。哦，我明白了。而且我想我们不得不从每个人那里得到许可。
you just keep going with the DP or whatever, and I'd walk out and I'd listen to him so that he could do it without me staring at him. I don't know what the issue was there. Well, I love the bloopers so much and my kids love the bloopers, so I've watched quite a lot of them. And I would say the person that breaks the most
是的，那是真的。因为它不酷就像只是泄漏试镜带。不，不，不，你是对的。它们在，我忘了是哪一季，但有一个DVD套装有大量的额外内容。它有像21分钟的花絮，它有，当每个人去斯克兰顿，它有演员采访，我想它有试镜带，它是一种纪念性的。
is Rain and his talking heads. Yes. He's all over the blue purse. His brain goes ahead of the material, like searching for alternates and stuff. Because he knows he has the ability to go off script and do his own thing. And so sometimes he would get ahead of the material
好吧，他们也做了那种像结局之前的回顾，他们也把我们的一些试镜带放在那里。是的。所以你记得我们所有人试镜的那个过程吗？当然。那是几个月。是的。
and start cracking up about what he could say. What he was going to say. What he was gonna say. That he knows is terribly wrong. Yeah. You know? Yeah. Yeah. We also talked earlier about all of the auditions.
好吧，有趣的事情是我们正在拍摄《报纸》是在路对面，在小简易别墅从Reveille是基于，我们有我们所有的试镜，我不知道你是否记得这个，但在那个简易别墅里坐了几个小时，它真的很有趣，因为电车就在它旁边过去。是的，为环球影城之旅。是的。电车。电车在它旁边过去，而且你知道每就像12分钟你听到某人进去，在这里是他们会找到明天的明星的地方，我们会坐在那里看着每个人。不，我记得，嗯，我的意思是，我确定我们以前谈论过这个，但你的试镜是如此
We went back in sort of honor of the 20th anniversary and we watched all these audition tapes. Cause they're online. Yeah. Yeah, it's weird, isn't it, that they're all out there? I mean. Yeah, they're not the full audition, you know, tapes are just little clips. No, I remember. We had to get permission, I think. They were a DVD extra. Oh, I see. And I think we had to get permission from everybody.
非凡珍娜，因为它就像等一下，这正是帕姆。我不明白她在做什么。她看起来真的什么都没做。然而她是100%的角色。而且很多，你知道，每个人都在大多数试镜中尝试得如此努力。而你几乎就像知道，就像不yes anding，你就像否定了即兴表演的所有建议。你记得那个吗？
Yeah, that's right. Because it's not cool to just like leak the audition tapes. No, no, no, you're right. They're on, I forget what season it is, but there's one DVD box set that has a whole bunch of extras. It has like 21 minutes of bloopers and it has the, when everyone went to Scranton and it has cast interviews and I think it has audition tapes, it's sort of a commemorative.
是的，这是一个有意识的决定。是的，它太棒了。我记得只是想，哦天哪，好吧，那是帕姆，我们知道那个。我非常确定我是在问你，我不能记住我是在问你还是艾莉森·琼斯在那之后，但我像，怎么，你在做什么？你怎么做这个？你知道吗？你确实。你说，我说了，好吧，我作为行政助理工作为了真实。
Well, they also did that sort of like retrospective before our finale and they put some of our audition tapes in there as well. Yeah. So do you remember that process of all of us auditioning? Sure. It was many months. Yeah.
那是过去七年我所做的。然后你就像，真的吗？真的吗？哇。是的。太疯狂了。而且我知道你在1-800牙医工作。是的。1-800牙医差点打破我。所以你有很多准确的办公室工作。什么很有趣是我想，但我当时不知道因为我的第一次试镜是为帕姆，但我真的只是，我知道安吉拉·马丁是谁，因为她是办公室经理。她是，而且她计划了圣诞派对。就像当我回顾它时，你知道，就像，而且，
Well, the funny thing is where we're shooting the paper is across the street on the lot from the little bungalow that Reveille was based at that we'd had all of our editions at and I don't know if you remember this but sitting in that bungalow hour after hour it's really funny because it's the tram goes right past it. Yes, for the Universal Studios tour. Yeah. The tram. The tram goes past it and you know every like 12 minutes you hear someone go in and here is where they're gonna find the stars of tomorrow and we'll be sitting there looking at everybody. No I remember well I mean I'm sure we've talked about this before but your audition was so
而且，她冲我大喊，因为我在办公室圣诞派对的楼梯扶手上做了一个错误的蝴蝶结。我第一次进去时并不知道所有这些。不，但我可以轻易地买到你曾在某一点提到那个，这就是为什么你是派对策划委员会的负责人。因为它双向工作，对吧？我的意思是，我们在听你在角色中关联的所有东西，通常那会变成剧本创意。
extraordinary Jenna because it was like wait a a second, this is exactly Pam. I don't understand what she's doing. She doesn't seem to really be doing anything. And yet she's 100% the character. And a lot of, you know, everybody was trying so hard in most auditions. And you were almost like knowing, like not yes anding, you were like negating all the suggestions for improv. Do you remember that?
是的，这是真的。我们谈论这个太多了，格雷格，因为我们从未有过像我们在《办公室》片场那样的经历。而且整个演员阵容都在谈论这个。这是因为你。这是因为你让我们感觉，即使情况并非总是如此，你让我们
Yeah, it was a conscious decision. Yeah, it was brilliant. And I remember just thinking like, oh my God, well, that's Pam, we know that. I'm pretty sure I was asking you, I can't remember if I was asking you or Alison Jones right afterwards, but I was like, how, what are you doing? How are you doing this? You know? You did. You said, and I said, well, I work as an administrative assistant for real.
感觉我们是创意合作的一部分，而且当我们为我们的角色说话，分享我们认为我们的角色会说什么时，我们的声音感觉被听到了。而且我知道已经20年了，但我会永远把它贴在我心里，你作为创造者和创造性的人为我们创造了那个环境。
That's what I've done for the last seven years. And you were like, really? Really? Wow. Yeah. That's crazy. And I know you worked at a 1-800 dentist. Yes. 1-800 dentists about broke me. So you had a lot of accurate office work. What was interesting is that I think, but I didn't know it at the time because my first audition was for Pam, but I really just, I knew who Angela Martin was because she was the office manager. She was, and she planned the Christmas party. Like when I look back on it, you know, like just,
好吧，那样更有趣。我想每个人都被激励参与。是的。因为你永远不知道我们会用什么。是的。但那也不仅仅是演员。有很多人是我们剧组的一部分，他们已经在行业中扩大了他们的角色，感谢你提供的机会和冠军。
and she, she yelled at me because I did a bow wrong on a stair banister for the office Christmas party. I didn't know all of that when I first went in. No, but I could easily buy that you at one point mentioned that and that's why you were the head of the party planning committee. Because it goes both ways, right? I mean, we were listening to everything that you related to in the character and often that would turn into script ideas.
你知道，我只是想到像兰德尔·艾因霍恩那样的人，他开始作为摄像机操作员DP，现在他是他自己的执行制片人，剧集主创，导演，多重连字符。是的。好吧，我会试着保留他作为DP。是的。他是一个非常好的DP。他非常棒。而且就像，实际上，我可以使用这个。我确信他仍然抓起相机并透过它看，也是。我确信。他有一个强大的创造性愿景，兰德尔。
Yeah, it's true. We talk about this so much, Greg, because we've never had an experience like we've had on the set of The Office. And the whole cast talks about this. It's because of you. It's because you made us feel, even if it wasn't always the case, you made us
他是我们发展的视觉风格的很大一部分。因为当我想到它，原始节目是电影非常Tae风格，非常就像悬挂。而且我注意到在重温试播集时有很多非常低的角度。真的很低，就像当简和……我们的试播集？我们的试播集。我们的试播集是真的很低，就像当简——我们的试播集？我们的试播集。我们的试播集是不同的DP，那是彼得·斯莫克勒。
feel like we were part of a creative collaboration, and that our voices felt heard when we spoke for our character, shared what we thought our character would say. And I know it's been 20 years, but I'll hold that forever close in my heart, that you created that environment for us as creators and creative people.
我知道，而且我认为他是在借鉴英国节目拍摄的方式，因为它们非常相似，然后当兰德尔来时，我注意到相机上了他的肩膀，而且那是一个不同的样子。好吧，斯莫克勒有一个这些设备，就像一个带电线的起重机，……
Well, it was more fun that way. I think everybody was energized to participate. Yes. Because you never knew what we would use. Yeah. But it wasn't just the actors too. There are so many people who were part of our crew that have expanded their roles in the industry thanks to the opportunities and the championship that you provided.
在安全带上？是的，它不是那么在肩膀上，而且兰德尔和马特·索恩来自你知道像《幸存者》这样的真人秀节目，有趣的事情是，在试播集和第一季之间，我不得不雇用一个编剧团队，因为试播集上没有编剧团队，所以当你雇用编剧团队时，你知道你读了大量的剧本，然后你和你喜欢的剧本作家有面试，所以我可能进行了50次面试，而且部分原因是你在向他们推销节目，因为如果你得到一个非常热门的作家，他们需要被稍微追求。
You know, I just think of someone like Randall Einhorn who started as a camera operator DP and now he's his own executive producer, showrunner, director, multi-hyphenate. Yeah. Well, I would have tried to keep him as a DP. Yeah. He's a very good DP. He's very good. And like, actually, I could use this. I'm sure he still grabs the camera and looks through it, too. I'm sure. He has a strong creative vision, Randall.
所以我试图想出一些胡说八道关于为什么这部剧是最重要的节目。你有你的推销。是的，我的推销。而且正如你知道的那样，我推销得越多，它某种程度上开始把它煮成某种东西。而且推销的一部分是，在YouTube和每个人都有一个便宜摄像机的世界里，人们在拍摄他们自己的东西，而且我们的节目是以你拍摄你自己的生活的方式拍摄的。对。然后我也有关于真人秀的另一件事，这是当时的新流派或无论是什么。所以到我完成面试所有这些作家时，我真的就像，在节目应该看起来像什么背后有一个强大的就像哲学。而且泰瑞·温伯格，你提到的，我记得她，我不确定确切她和本是怎么联系到这些真人秀摄像机操作员的，但我认为他们也在做真人秀节目，像《最大的失败者》之类的。
He was so much a part of the visual style that we developed. Because when I think about it, the original show was cinema very Tae style, very kind of hang back. And a lot of very low angles I noticed in rewatching the pilot. Really low, like when Jan and... Our pilot? Our pilot. Our pilot was Really low, like when Jan- Our pilot? Our pilot. Our pilot was different DP, that was Peter Smokler.
是的，Reveille做了《最大的失败者》。是的。所以我就是这样见到兰德尔的。而且这是一个太棒的增加了难题的部分，开始倾向于这种真人秀氛围。我的意思是，你说的那非常有意义。我不知道为什么我从来没有想过它，但就像我们过去持有摄像机的方式正是观点。
I know, and I think he was borrowing from that way that the British show was shot, cause they're very similar, and then when Randall came on, I noticed that camera went up on his shoulder, and it was a different look. Well, Smokler had one of these devices that was like a crane with a wire that...
而且那太神奇了。我从来没有想过那个。是的，它与手机略有不同，我想。至少我拿着手机的方式。但如果你真的擅长手机，它们有小的把手之类的，所以手机不会摇晃。是的。
On the harness? Yeah, it wasn't so much on the shoulder and Randall and Matt Sohn came from you know reality shows like Survivor and the interesting thing was that in between the pilot and season one I had to hire a writing staff because there was no writing staff on the pilot and so when you're hiring a writing staff you know you read tons of scripts and then you have interviews with the script writers that you like so I probably had 50 interviews and part of it is you're pitching the show to them because if you're getting a really hot writer they need to be wooed a little bit.
是的。好吧，现在你正在做《报纸》，但你完成了拍摄。我们完成了拍摄第一季。目前，在这一点上，我们锁定了前十集中的六集图片。那很令人兴奋。是的。是的。而且它很令人兴奋。是的，是的。而且它很令人兴奋。而且有很多我们的老剧组在这个节目上。
So I would try to come up with some bullsh** about why this show was the most important show. You had your sales pitch. Yeah, my sales pitch. And as you know, the more I pitched it, the more it sort of started to boil it into something. And part of the sales pitch was that in a world of YouTube and everybody having a cheap camcorder that people were shooting their own stuff and our show was shot the
凯利·坎特利和卡莎·特罗贾克和拉斯蒂·马哈茂德，他们都是，就像整个AD团队是同一个人，而且塞尔吉奥正在为它餐饮。你太好了。你邀请我们去片场。我们还没分享它。但当我们看到我们的剧组，当我们看到塞尔吉奥时，我们几乎失去了我们的头脑。
way you shoot your own life. Right. And then I also had another thing about reality shows and this is the new genre or whatever at the time. So by the time I had finished interviewing all these writers, I really was like, had a strong like philosophy behind how the show should look. And Terry Weinberg, who you mentioned, I remember her, I'm not sure exactly how she and Ben like came into contact with these reality show camera operators, but I think they were also doing reality programming, like Biggest Loser or something.
然后我就像，塞尔吉奥，你仍然做你的莎莎酱吗？他就像，是的。所以，我的意思是，看到那些脸真是太棒了。是的，有他们在周围非常愉快。而且他们让你保持诚实，就像本·帕特里克在做声音，在某一点他来到我这里，他就像这个不对。你做的不对。而且你知道，我有一次不得不谈论他从树上下来。好吧，当我们在那里时，在片场发生的事情之一，我想我可以讲这个故事，你告诉我如果不行。
Yeah, Reveille did Biggest Loser. Yeah. So that's how I met Randall. And it was a terrific added piece of the puzzle to start leaning into this reality vibe. I mean, it makes perfect sense that you say that. I don't know why I haven't ever thought of it, but just the way we used to hold camcorders is exactly the point of view.
而且有一部分人，所以我心想，哦，我会很友好，我会只是走过来，我会说，我就像，哦，你们都在节目上做什么？他们都说，哦，我们是员工。哦，对，对，对。在背景中。是的。而且我们一直在坐在这里。
And that's amazing. I had never thought of that before. Yeah, it's slightly different with phones, I think. At least the way I hold a phone. But if you're really good at phones, they have little handles and stuff and so that the phone doesn't wiggle around. Yeah.
而且那是他们的位置。我就像，我做了那个！我坐，他们就像，我们是在节目上。但我们坐在这里，因为我们在那一刻的背景中。他们甲板上。是的，我就想，哦天哪，那就是我们所做的。我们所有人都一直坐在那里。
Yeah. Well now you're working on the paper, but you finished shooting. We finished shooting the first season. At the moment, at this point, we've locked picture on six of the first ten. That's exciting. Yeah. Yeah. And it is exciting. Yeah, yeah. And it is exciting. And there's a lot of our old crew on the show.
而且我认为我们的节目成功的原因之一是因为我们所有人都一直坐在那里。我们都在其中一直。是的。好吧，我想有很多原因，我认为，为什么我们的节目工作。我的意思是，演员，首先也是最重要的。但演员和剧组在一起其中的精神非常特别。
Kelly Cantley and Kasha Trojack and Rusty Mahmood, they're all, like the whole AD staff is the same guys and Sergio is catering it. You were so nice. You invited us to set. We haven't shared about it yet. But when we saw our crew, when we saw Sergio, we about lost our minds.
而且我想我有从蒙提·派森得到的很多理论，我想，那对我来说是一个巨大的节目。当我12岁时，蒙提·派森在美国出来。我只是就像，当你是一个12岁的人，那是喜剧。我向你的大致方向战斗。是的，不，完全正确。
And I was like, Sergio, do you still make your salsa? And he was like, yeah. So, I mean, that was wonderful to see those faces. Yeah, it's very nice to have them around. And they keep you honest, like Ben Patrick was doing sound and at one point he came to me he was like this isn't right. You're not doing it right. And you know I had to talk him out of a tree at one point. Well one of the things that happened on the set when we were there, I think I can tell this story, you tell me if not.
是的，所以我们总是会那样做。但我的意思是，关于蒙提·派森的事情是作家和表演者是同一个人。而且你只是可以得到他们所有人住在某个房子里变得越来越奇怪的感觉，就像这个小邪教从社会分裂出来。是的，所以我肯定在试图鼓励那个与我们的小组。
And there was a section of people and so I thought, oh, I'll be friendly and I'll just come over and I'll say, I'm like, oh, what do you all do on the show? And they all said, oh, we're employees. Oh, right, right, right. In the background. Yeah. And we sit here all the time.
好吧，当我看着照片时我喜欢的事情之一是那个照片当我们包装时，你知道，那个最后的时刻，我们所有人都在场景中一起只是走出那栋楼，而且剧组聚集周围当你正要喊，你知道，最后一次切断。我觉得那就是我们的节目，就是那间大房间的人。是的。
And that was their spot. And I was like, I did that! I sat, they're like, we are on the show. But we're sitting here because we're in the background of this moment. They're on deck. Yes, and I was like, oh my gosh, that's what we did. We all sat there all the time.
你知道吗？而且我们错过了我们的包装派对。你记得吗？是的，是的，是的。我们迟到了我们自己的派对，这本身就很完美。是的，因为派对正在做节目，所以没人想要那个派对结束。
And I think one of the reasons why our show was successful was because we were all there all the time. We were all in it all the time. Yeah. Well, there's a lot of reasons, I think, why our show worked. I mean, the cast, first and foremost. But the spirit of the cast and crew being in it together was very special.
而且那个派对你在租来的仓库里喝姜汁汽水不会像那么好。就像那一刻，是的。那是我想再做一次的时刻之一，我想。你会再次包装系列？不，只是那个。但我就是那个意思，就像那个同志情的时刻。那种同志情的感觉真的很特别
And I think I had a lot of theories that I got from Monty Python, I think, which was a huge show for me. When I'm 12, Monty Python comes out in the US. And I'm just like, when you're a 12-year-old, that's the comedy. I fought in your general direction. Yeah, no, exactly.
而且有那张神奇的照片。我不知道我为什么在流泪，但我认为只是因为它就是那一刻当我们某种程度上集体说再见是如此强大而且只是特别。而且你知道。结局确实很好。是的。不是吗？是的。我认为那有很大的区别，因为我认为有
Yeah, so we would always do that. But I mean, the thing about Monty Python was the writers and the performers were the same people. And you could just get this feeling of them all living in a house somewhere getting weirder and weirder together, like this little cult that had split off from society. Yeah, so I was definitely trying to encourage that with our little group.
很多人看结局，然后他们只是把它加大到第一季。开始看再次。是的。我得到了它。我真的在我们的重温中得到了它，并且看过一些我没看过自从我们制作它们以来的这些剧集。我只是就像，我准备好再次开始。就像我们昨天看了试播集，我就像，好吧，我准备好再次看它。我们改变。角色确实成长，但他们成长真的很慢，以一种非常满足的方式。所以我认为那是关于一遍又一遍地看它并重新开始的一件令人愉快的事情，就是你真的在与这些人进行旅程的开始。而且它甚至有趣知道现在他们会结束在哪里。是的，当然。当你回去并且
Well, one of the things I love when I look back at pictures is that picture when we wrapped, you know, that final moment and how we were all in the scene together just walking out of the building and the crew had all gathered around when you were about to yell, you know, cut for the last time. I felt like that was our show, was that big room of people. Yeah.
看第二遍。你有没有，你有没有见过一个纪录片叫《7 Up》当它开始时？是的，14 Up，21 Up。我不知道他们现在到了什么。他们就像63 Up之类的。它是但它是一每七年他们检查这个英国人组谁开始作为七岁的人。是的，它真的移动看到他们发生了什么。但我认为那部分节目的骨头是它是一个纪录片为了真实，而且它能点击一些使纪录片情感的事情。而且结局就像那样。
You know? And we were missing our wrap party. Do you remember? Yes, yes, yes. We were late to our own party, which is kind of perfect in itself. Yeah, because the party was doing the show, so nobody wanted that party to end.
它某种程度上就像人们总结他们的生活而且你知道。是的。是的。所以当你回去看试播集在这个我们看的粉丝超级版是一个吉姆谈话头被扩展了我没看过。而且那是重温中的事情之一。有这么多谈话头我没看过因为我们不在那里当我们拍摄彼此的谈话头，你知道吗？对。所以有所有这些像惊喜而且吉姆说，好吧，让我们看，我不结婚，
And the party where you're drinking ginger ale in some rented warehouse was not going to be as good. As right that moment, yeah. That's one of the moments I would do again, I think. You would wrap the series again? No, just that. But that's what I mean, like that moment of camaraderie. That feeling of camaraderie is really special
我没有孩子，但我能买一辆车。所以我有一辆车而且我的车五岁了而且我只是就像，然后我想起所有的地方，吉姆去哪里，你知道，而且他结束在哪里以及他的生活。而且我只是在思考那个。那正是你所谈论的。我觉得我看着他成为他完全实现的自我。是的。试播集的很多额外内容
and there's that amazing picture. And I don't know why I'm tearing up, but I think just because it's that moment when we sort of collectively said goodbye was so powerful and just special. And you know. The finale really turned out well. Yeah. Didn't it? Yeah. I think that makes a big difference because I think there's so
是东西我添加到英国剧本而且然后当我们不得不把它切减到时间很多那些不得不去，不得不去因为原始故事有所有的节拍在其中但很多那些小优雅笔记很好。好吧，粉丝超级剧集看起来真的很满足。它真的很，真的很愉快看。哦，那很好。而且你得到感觉那个英国试播集与然后哪里你可以知道我们的节目最终会去。是瞄准，是的。
many people who watch the finale and then they just crank it up to season one again. Start watching again. Yeah. I get it. I really get it in our rewatch and having seen some of these episodes I haven't seen since we made them. I'm just like, I'm ready to start again. Like we watched the pilot yesterday and I'm like, well, I'm ready to watch it again. We change. The characters do grow, but they grow really slowly in a way that's very satisfying. And so I think that's one of the things that is enjoyable about watching it again and again and starting over is that you really are starting at the beginning of a journey with these people. And it's kind of even fun to know now where they're gonna end up. Yeah, for sure. As you go back and
是的。它很酷。我喜欢我们看了整个原始广播而且现在我们得到看，它就像我们得到了甜点，你知道吗？而且我欣赏它。然后，你知道，我们在和戴夫·罗杰斯谈论它而且只是绝对的关心和完整性他想要确保这些超级粉丝剧集
watch the second time. Did you ever, have you ever seen a documentary that was called 7 Up when it started? Yes, 14 Up, 21 Up. I don't know what they're up to now. They're like 63 Up or something. It's but it's it's every seven years they check in with this group of British people who start as seven-year-olds. Yeah, it's really moving to to see what happens to them. But I think that part of the bones of the show is that it is a documentary for real and it can tap into some of the things that make documentaries emotional. And the finale was like that.
不要冒险太远离原始任务。而且我只是就像，它们不能在更好的手手中而且我知道他直接和你一起在上面而且我们非常感谢戴夫是某种程度上在帮忙所有那些。哦上帝是的，好吧，戴夫真的是节目每一刻的保管人。哦那是一个如此美丽的短语。是的，他只是知道关于它的一切。是的。而不是像谁是，夫人6.0笑话。而且笑话在其中。好吧，在我们继续这一采访的最后部分之前，我知道每个人都会想要我们问，你不必回答，但我们必须问你关于这个新闻故事出来关于某个某人谁可能在报纸上。
It was kind of like people summing their lives up and you know. Yeah. Yeah. So when you go back and watch the pilot in this superfan version that we watched was a Jim talking head that was extended that I hadn't seen. And that's one of the things in the rewatch. There's so many talking heads I hadn't seen because we're not there when we film each other's talking heads, you know? Right. So there's all these kind of surprises and Jim says, well, let's see, I'm not married,
某个来自办公室的角色，奥斯卡。是的，好吧，我们现在可以确认。你记得当你访问片场时，有极端的保密围绕。是的，他甚至没有被叫奥斯卡，就像在剧本上之类的。好吧，我的希望是第一个预告片或者第一段片段它会是一个惊喜。就像当史蒂夫出现在
I don't have kids, but I was able to buy a car. So I have a car and my car is five years old and I'm just like, then I think about all the places that, where Jim goes, you know, and where he ends up and his life. And I was just thinking about that. That's exactly what you're talking about. I felt like I had watched him become his fully realized self. Yeah. A lot of the extras for the pilot
结局。是的，保持一个惊喜很难在这个时代与娱乐新闻的数量而且某人闻到了它。某人怎么闻到它？我不知道但你知道我的意思是，有很多时候电车会过去而且奥斯卡会就像潜到垃圾桶后面之类的。当我们访问时，电车过去而且NBC，协调我们访问的协调员，他们就像，走开，走开从旅行。就像他们不想电车看到我们访问。我们潜到拖车后面然后一个女人
were stuff that I had added to the British script and then when we had to cut it down to time a lot of those had to go, had to go because the original story was had all the beats in it but a lot of those little grace notes were nice. Well the superfan episode is really satisfying to watch. It's really, really fun to watch. Oh, that's good. And you get to feel that difference between the British pilot and then where you can know that our show is eventually going. Is aiming at, yeah.
谁只是碰巧走过那块地看到我们然后就像，哦天哪，而且要求我们的照片。我们说了是的，我们像当然。而且那NBC女人冲出来说，你必须，你不能发布那个，你不能。而且我们就像，哦，然后她就像，OK，你们伙计们进你们的车。就像，是的。好吧，它很有趣因为我总是觉得
Yeah. It's cool. I like that we've watched the whole original broadcast and now we get to see, it's like we got a dessert, you know? And I appreciate it. And then, you know, we were talking to Dave Rogers about it and just the absolute care and integrity that he wants to make sure that these super fan episodes
对于惊喜来说在观看节目体验时命中更有趣。而且，你知道，对于一个普通人谁将会看节目几年后而不注意无论启动前宣传是什么。是的，博客之类的。它只是会看它。所以你想建立它以便惊喜是为观看节目的人准备的。但有时它非常困难去推广事情如果你试图保持一个秘密。而且所以例如，我
do not venture too far off the original mission. And I'm just like, they could not be in better hands hands and I know he's working directly with you on them and we're so thankful that Dave is is sort of helping with all of that. Oh god yeah well Dave is really the custodian of every moment of the show. Oh that's such a beautiful phrase. Yeah he just knows everything about it. Yeah. As opposed to who's like, Mrs. 6.0 joke. And joke in it. Well, before we move on to the final part of this interview, I know everybody's gonna want us to ask, you don't have to answer, but we have to ask you about this news story that came out about a certain somebody who might be on the paper.
也在放置最后润色在《上传》的最后季节，第四季，而且我们结束第三季在一个巨大的悬疑关于我们的主角内森的哪个版本，罗比·阿梅尔。他是，你知道，一个数字人谁一直被上传。而且有在某一点他被非法复制而且有两个人在第三季。然后我们某种程度上结束在一个悬疑其中之一被销毁。而且总之，所以我们就像，哦酷，这将会是一个如此令人兴奋的开始到第四季。而且，你知道，当你发现哪一个。而且现在我意识到就像，我不知道怎么推广这个因为所有，而且你知道，当你发现哪一个。而且现在我意识到，就像，我不知道怎么推广这个
A certain character from the office, Oscar. Yes, well, we can now confirm. You remember that when you visited the set, there was extreme secrecy around. Yes, he wasn't even called Oscar, like on the script and stuff. Well, my hope was that the first promo or the first piece of footage that it would be a surprise. Like when Steve showed up in the
因为所有，你知道，任何片段。所有的片段非常清晰。它将会使它变得相当清楚哪一个，你知道，哪一个幸存，但我当时没沿着那些路线想。但是是的，所以我确实在试图保护奥斯卡成为一个有趣的惊喜对于人们看新节目去突然意识到他是它的一部分。你知道，节目的本质故事，我的意思是，奥斯卡的精彩，它不是衍生
finale. Yes it's very difficult to keep a surprise nowadays with the amount of entertainment journalism and somebody sniffed it out. How did someone sniff it out? I don't know but you know mean, there was a lot of times where the tram would go by and Oscar would like dive behind a trash can or something. When we were visiting, the tram went by and the NBC, the coordinator who had coordinated our visit, they were like, move away, move away from the trip. Like they didn't want the tram to see us visiting. We dove behind a trailer and then a woman
系列对于奥斯卡发生了什么，它更多是纪录片团队看周围寻找别的东西去做关于纪录片，而且发现这张报纸已经陷入困难时期，像大多数报纸一样，而且甚至没有预算给任何记者。所以想法是一个非常理想主义的人进来去试着放这张报纸回到它的脚上而且发现那是唐纳德·格里森，发现他没有预算去雇用记者
who just happened to be walking through the lot saw us and was like, oh my gosh, and asked for our picture. We said yes, we're like sure. And that NBC woman sprinted out and said, you have to, you can't post that, you can't. And we were like, oh, and she was like, okay, you guys get in your cars. Like, yeah. Well, it's interesting because I always feel like
而且不得不把现有的广告推销员和会计和卡车司机的员工变成记者去为报纸做一些内容而且他们不知道他们在做什么而且，你知道，欢闹随之而来。好吧，我们非常兴奋看它。你知道它什么时候会播出吗？你有播出日期吗？我想可能在秋天，像回到学校的那种事情。就像旧日子。
it's more fun for surprises to hit while you're having the experience of watching the show. And, you know, for an ordinary person who is gonna watch the show several years later without paying attention to whatever the pre-launch publicity was. Yeah, blogs and stuff. It's just going to be watching it. So you want to build it so that the surprises are for the people watching the show. But sometimes it's very difficult to promote things if you're going to try and keep a secret. And so for instance, I
好吧，我们迫不及待地想看《报纸》，而且你会让我们知道当我们能开始分享关于它时。是的，当然。是的。OK。谢谢。所以格雷格，我们开始问我们的客人的通告单问题。这就是我们称呼它们。
am also putting the finishing touches on the last season of Upload, season four, and we ended season three on an enormous cliffhanger of which version of our lead character, Nathan, Robbie Amell. He's, you know, a digital person who's been uploaded. And there's, at some point he was illegally copied and there's two of them in season three. And then we sort of ended on this cliffhanger of one of them has been destroyed. And anyway, so we were like, oh cool, this is gonna be such an exciting beginning to season four. And, you know, when you find out which one. And now I'm realizing like, I don't know how to promote this because all of, and you know, when you find out which one. And now I'm realizing, like, I don't know how to promote this
这些是通告单背面上的问题当我们将会认识一个剧组人员。所以我们将问你办公室通告单问题。OK。准备好了吗？问题第一。你的第一份娱乐工作是什么？啊哈哈。好吧，我会告诉你我跟踪它从它不是一份真正的工作但我的父亲为首都城市广播工作作为他的职业当我是一个孩子而且他在不同的广播电台工作而且在某一点他是罗德岛一个摇滚广播电台的经理而且他过去去这个经理会议为所有
because all of the, you know, any clip. All of the footage is very clear. It's gonna make it pretty clear which one, you know, which one survived, but I wasn't thinking along those lines. But yeah, so I was really trying to protect Oscar to be a fun surprise for people watching the new show to suddenly realize that he was a part of it. You know, the essential story of the show, I mean, Oscar's wonderful, it's not the spin-off
其他电台经理而且他在会议娱乐。他有一个卡纳克风格的表演在哪里他有他会……就像约翰尼·卡森？就像约翰尼·卡森在哪里他会把信封放带他的头而且，你知道，读答案而且然后打开信封而且那里会有笑话。所以我为他写笑话为那个表演，而且我们已经在节目中用了它。我记得那个。你记得这个？对，对。
series for what happens to Oscar, it's more the show of the documentary crew looking around for something else to do a documentary about and finding this newspaper that has fallen on hard times, like most newspapers, and does not even have a budget for any reporters. So the idea is that a very idealistic person comes in to try and put this newspaper back on its feet and finds out that's Donald Gleason, finds out that he doesn't have the budget to hire reporters
当迈克尔做它时。是的，而且我们用了同样的笑话。那是我的第一个笑话。你多大了？我就像一个青少年，而且他做了很多年。而且最后，各种我的朋友为他写。而且在某一点，他有柯南为他写而且这个家伙，迈克·里斯，他是编剧主管
and has to turn the existing staff of ad salespeople and accountants and truck drivers into reporters to make some content for the paper and they don't know what they're doing and, you know, hilarity ensues. Well, we're so excited to watch it. Do you know when it's going to air? Do you have an air date? I think probably in the fall, like a back to school kind of a thing. Like it's like the old days.
《辛普森一家》的，谁之前，而且显然之前，他们有大的职业。所以在你父亲的员工圈和只是朋友圈，他们只是认为你的父亲是他们见过最有趣的人吗？是的。他有最好的喜剧作家为他。我偷了一吨故事。我的父亲经历了许多有趣的事情而且他把它们变成了非常有趣的故事
Well, we can't wait to watch the paper and you'll let us know when we can start sharing about it. Yes, of course. Yes. Okay. Thank you. So Greg, we've started asking our guests the call sheet questions. That's what we call them.
而且我用了它们。所以例如，我写了一集《宋飞正传》它是100%基于我的父亲，他在纽约市住而且他有一辆车但它太贵去拥有一个车库。所以每两天他会开车周围寻找一个停车空间。而且有时它会花费45分钟一个小时
These were the questions on the back of our call sheets where we would get to know a crew member. So we're going to ask you the office call sheet questions. Okay. Ready? Question number one. What was your first entertainment job? Ah ha ha. Well, I'll tell you that I track it from it's not really a job but my father worked for Capital Cities broadcasting as his career when I was a kid and he worked at different radio stations and at one point he was a manager of a rock radio station in Rhode Island and he used to go to this manager's meeting for all of
去寻找一个停车空间。所以在一会花费45分钟，一个小时去寻找一个停车空间。所以在一特定点他找到了一个，他如此兴奋，而且他开始倒车进去。而且这另一个家伙试图正面进入它。而且他们俩谁都不会让步。我记得那一集。你记得这一集吗？是的，而且它就像停车位的对峙。
the other station managers and he entertained at the meeting. He had a Karnak style act where he had he would... Like Johnny Carson? Like Johnny Carson where he would put a envelope up to his head and, you know, read the answers and then open up the envelope and there would be the joke. So I wrote jokes for him for that act, and we've used it in the show. I remember that. Do you remember this? Right, right.
是的，而且这发生在他身上，而且他不会离开。而且他的一个朋友走过而且他标记他下来，而且他让他，你让他告诉我的妈妈做饭给他而且把它带到停车位。所以我把那个推销给拉里·大卫而且卖那个作为自由撰稿人剧集。所以我感觉我已经从他那里拿走了足够多，我很高兴给了他，你知道，笑话为他的经理表演。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个太多了。
When Michael does it. Yes, and we used the same joke. That was my first joke. How old were you? I was like a teenager, and he did it for many years. And eventually, various friends of mine wrote for him. And at one point, he had Conan writing for him, and this guy, Mike Reese, who was one of the showrunners
所以那会是我的第一。我的意思是，那不是一份有薪水的工作。第一份有薪水的工作是柯南和我可能工作为不一定是那个时候的新闻。作为写作伙伴？是的，我们是写作伙伴。是的。在那个时候。作为写作伙伴？是的，我们是写作伙伴。下一个问题。你讲任何其他语言或演奏乐器吗？
of The Simpsons, who before, and obviously before, they had big careers. So in your dad's employee circle and just circle of friends, do they just think your dad is the funniest person they've ever met? Yes. He had the best comedy writers for him. I've stolen a ton of stories. My dad has lived through a lot of funny things and he turns them into very funny stories
非常有趣你应该带出那个因为我正在敲击Duolingo现在。什么语言？我正在做西班牙语和法语而且葡萄牙语和日语。我正在尝试一大堆。看看什么贴。是的，好吧有时你是，你知道，主要是西班牙语。我在西班牙语中取得最大进展，但有时我会尝试一些其他的。而且我只是上周在麦凯布吉他店而且我正在听音乐会
and I've used them. So for instance, I wrote an episode of Seinfeld that was 100% based on my dad, where he lived in New York City and he had a car but it was too expensive to have a garage. So every two days he would drive around looking for a parking space. And sometimes it would take 45 minutes an hour
而且某人正在弹奏曼陀林而且我就想，该死，我得学习怎么弹奏曼陀林在我死之前。我真的想学习那个，但我真的没有音乐能力。克里德弹曼陀林。他吗？我敢打赌他很棒。好吧，下一个问题。一个你去过的地方你绝对喜欢？好吧，我就像，某种程度上就像无论我去哪里，我总是就像，我能住在这儿吗？这很酷。
to find a parking space. So at one would take 45 minutes, an hour to find a parking space. So at one point he found one, he was so excited, and he started to back into it. And this other guy tried to front into it. And neither of them would budge. I remember that episode. Do you remember this episode? Yes, and it was like a standoff in the parking spot.
而且我记得开车到洛杉矶与柯南和另一个朋友，罗布·莱兹布尼克，去有工作在不一定是新闻。而且我们开车经过圣达菲，新墨西哥州。而且我记得像，哦天哪，这个地方很神奇。我怎么能在这里工作？而且唯一我觉得我可能能工作上的工作是报纸，因为他们在那里有一份报纸。
Yeah, and this happened to him, and he wouldn't leave. And a friend of his walked by and he flagged him down, and he had him, you know him tell my mom to make him dinner and bring it to the parking spot. And so I pitched that to Larry David and sold that as a freelance episode. So I feel like I've taken enough from him where I'm happy to have given him, you know, jokes for his manager act. I love that. I love that so much.
所以我有一个小幻想住在圣达菲而且为无论他们的报纸是什么工作。我的姻亲住在圣达菲。真的吗？是的，李的父亲和继母住在圣达菲。住在圣达菲而且为无论他们的报纸是什么工作。我的姻亲住在圣达菲。真的吗？是的，李的父亲和继母住在圣达菲。那不酷吗？我们总是去那里。我喜欢那里空气的气味。
So that would be my first. I mean, that wasn't a paid job. First paid job was Conan and I probably working for not necessarily the news back in the day. As writing partners? Yes, we were writing partners. Yeah. Back in the day. As writing partners? Yes, we were writing partners. Next question. Do you speak any other languages or play a musical instrument?
它只是就像。好吧，你知道，它是非常高的海拔，实际上。某种程度上悄悄地接近你。但我们在大流行病期间搬到圣达菲去更接近他们。而且那是我们的吊舱。那很酷。我的意思是那真的非常酷。它很棒。
It's so funny you should bring that up because I am pounding away at Duolingo right now. What language? I'm doing Spanish and French and both Portuguese and Japanese. I'm trying a whole bunch. To see what sticks. Yeah, well sometimes you're, you know, mostly Spanish. I'm making the most progress in Spanish, but sometimes I'll try some other ones. And I just was at McCabe's guitar shop last week and I was listening to a concert
它很棒。是的。OK。问题四，你喜欢在周末做什么？好吧你知道我仍然有不能开车的孩子。我最小的正在学习怎么开车而且所以我的周末主要是开车带她周围。是的。我可以关联。
and somebody was playing a mandolin and I was like, God damn it, I gotta learn how to play the mandolin before I die. I really want to learn that, but I have really no musical ability. Creed plays the mandolin. Does he? I'll bet he's great. All right, next question. What's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved? Well, I'm like, kind of like no matter where I go, I'm always like, could I live here? This is cool.
我说什么，我只是家长优步，你知道吗？是的。所以。那就是你在周末做什么。是的。你喜欢在周末做什么？我不需要。没有。
And I remember driving out to LA with Conan and another friend, Rob Lzebnik, to have jobs at not necessarily the news. And we drove through Santa Fe, New Mexico. And I remember being like, oh my god, this place is magical. How could I work here? And the only job that I thought I might be able to work on was the newspaper, because they had a newspaper there.
没有做梦的点。你只是让它去。直到她拿到她的驾驶执照。那将会改变你的生活。是的。好吧，最后一个问题。你最喜欢的午夜零食是什么？哦伙计，我只是……他的儿子有一个食谱他们与我分享当他在一年级时。
So I had a little fantasy of living in Santa Fe and working for whatever their newspaper was. My in-laws live in Santa Fe. Really? Yeah, Lee's dad and stepmom live in Santa Fe. Living in Santa Fe and working for whatever their newspaper was. My in-laws live in Santa Fe. Really? Yeah, Lee's dad and stepmom live in Santa Fe. Isn't that cool? We go there all the time. I love the smell of the air there.
这是世界上最容易做的事情。它是希腊酸奶和自发粉混合，而且它成为一个面团。而且你然后可以烘烤它，而且你可以做百吉饼从中。你可以做饼干从中。它就像一个好的面团。所以我一直在做这些日子是把不同的东西放在它里面而且制作像一个手派。是的，就像一个小热口袋。
It's just like. Well, you know, it's very high elevation, actually. Kind of sneaks up on you. But we moved to Santa Fe during the pandemic to be closer to them. And that was our pod. That's cool. I mean that's really cool. It's great.
就像你放在它里面什么？我把它放在烤面包机里。我放了一些鸡肉和洋葱在午夜，另一个晚上。你鞭打一个从零开始的面团。它不是。哦天哪。那听起来真的很好。
It's great. Yeah. Okay. Question number four, what do you like to do on the weekends? Well you know I still have kids who can't drive. My youngest is just learning how to drive and so my weekends are mostly driving her around. Yeah. I can relate.
是的。是的。那是一个点击你为那个食谱，实际上。你刚听到了。没有新的东西。比例是多少？50-50。哦，所以一杯面团和一杯酸奶。
I say something, I'm just parent Uber, you know? Yeah. So. That's what you do on the weekends. Yeah. What do you like to do on the weekends? I don't need to. There's no.
就像一杯酸奶，一杯面粉。对。一杯面粉，一杯酸奶。而且保持它到两个成分，它是自发粉，也就是基本上已经有发酵粉混合在其中的面粉。但你可以只是放入一茶匙发酵粉到一杯面粉。然后你揉它起来，
There's no point in having dreams. You just let it go. Until she gets her driver's license. That's going to change your life. Yeah. All right, last question. What is your favorite midnight snack? Oh man, I just... His son had a recipe that they shared with me when he was in first grade.
而且然后你可以只是放东西在它里面。而且你按它进入托盘随附于……烤面包机，而且然后你放无论什么填充你想要在它上面，而且你只是某种程度上折叠襟翼上去而且试着密封它起来。你烘烤它多久？我不知道，25分钟，没关系。
It's the easiest thing to make in the world. It's Greek yogurt and self-rising flour mixed, and it becomes a dough. And you can then bake it, and you can make a bagel out of it. You can make a biscuit out of it. It's like a good dough. And so what I've been doing lately is putting different things inside of it and making like a hand pie. Yeah, like a little hot pocket.
你不能真正过度烘烤它那么多。只是变得有点更脆。它不是像精确的科学。格雷格，我们已经问过很多人这个问题，而且那是唯一的答案。我喜欢它。我们已经问过很多人这个问题而且那是唯一的答案我们得到了。我喜欢它。
Like what do you put inside it? I put it in the toaster oven. I put in some chicken and onions the middle of the night, the other night. You whip up a from scratch dough. It's not. Oh my gosh. That sounds really good.
哦，格雷格，非常感谢你进来标记这一场合。好吧，它总是如此有趣。我喜欢你的节目。而且你知道，显然，我非常感兴趣你的节目的内容。我们做得还可以吗？我们得到了它对吗？是的，它太棒了。它太棒了，你知道。
Yeah. Yeah. That is a hit you up for that recipe, actually. You just heard it. There's no nothing new. What are the proportions? 50-50. Oh, so a cup of dough and a cup of yogurt.
而且你们总是做你们的家庭作业如此好而且你们总是有一系列有趣的提问而且一个如此有趣的经历来到节目而且和你们闲逛。我错过了有你在我的日常生活中。啊，格雷格。非常感谢。我感觉同样的方式。
Like cup of yogurt, cup of flour. Right. Cup of flour, cup of yogurt. And to keep it to two ingredients, it's self-rising flour, which is basically flour that already has baking powder mixed into it. But you could just put in a teaspoon of baking powder to a cup of flour. And then you knead it up,
谢谢。好吧，我们也太赞赏粉丝发送精彩问题。所以我们必须就像感谢他们为了帮助激发我们去问你我们确实问你的事情，但什么快乐去见到你。而且我们迫不及待去谈论更多关于《报纸》与你当当你准备好。
and then you can just put something in it. And you press it into the tray that comes with the... The toaster oven, and then you put whatever filling you want on top of it, and you just kind of fold the flaps up and try and seal it up. How long do you bake it for? I don't know, 25 minutes, doesn't matter.
当然。而且我迫不及待对于人们去看它。我的希望是如果你喜欢办公室，你会喜欢这个新东西因为它有一些音调相似之处。是的，而且一个伟大的演员。精彩的演员和作家。一些奇妙的演员。是的。所以，而且剧组我们都知道。
You can't really over bake it that much. Just gets a little crustier. It's not like exact science. Greg, we have asked so many people this question, and that is the most unique answer. I love it. We have asked so many people this question and that is the most unique answer that we have gotten. I love it.
是的，好吧，我们在世界上。好吧，格雷格。好吧，我们爱你太多。非常感谢你在这里。OK。祝你有一个伟大的广播剩余部分。我开始了那个而且我不知道怎么结束它。你确实做了事情无论什么时候，就像，我们开玩笑关于这个，就像当我们不知道怎么出去某事，我们要么唱它要么我们做一个声音。是的，我变成了一个老渔夫。
Oh, Greg, thank you so much for coming in and marking this occasion. Well, it's always so fun. I love your show. And you know, obviously, I'm very interested in the content of your show. Are we doing okay? Did we get it right? Yeah, it's fabulous. It's fabulous, you know.
你确实。谢谢，格雷格。谢谢。谢谢你监听办公室女士。办公室女士是一个奥德赛的呈现而且由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。而且我们的副制片人是安斯利·布巴科。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼，而且音频团队的导演是萨姆·基弗。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。
And you guys always do your homework so well and you always have such interesting questions and such a fun experience to come on the show and to hang out with you guys. I miss having you in my daily life. Aw, Greg. Thank you so much. I feel the same way.
我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们在这里有很多伟大的人。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。而且我们的副制片人是安斯利·布巴科。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和利亚·里斯-丹尼斯。
Thank you. Well, we so appreciate too the fans send in fantastic questions. So we have to like thank them for helping inspire us to ask you the things we do ask you, but what a joy to see you. And we can't wait to talk more about the paper with you when you're ready.
办公室女士是由克里斯·巴西尔混合和掌握。我们的主题曲是Ruppertree由克里德·布拉顿。你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子去留下一个评论。
Sure. And I can't wait for people to see it. My hope is that if you like the office, you'll like this new thing because it has some tonal similarities. Yeah, and a great cast. Fantastic cast and writers. Some marvelous cast. Yeah. So, and crew that we all know.
当然。我迫不及待想让大家看到它。我希望如果你喜欢《办公室》，你也会喜欢这部新作品，因为它们在基调上有相似之处。是的，还有很棒的演员阵容。出色的演员和编剧。非常棒的演员阵容。是的。还有我们大家都熟悉的剧组人员。
Yes, well, we're in the world. All right, Greg. Well, we love you so much. Thank you so much for being here. Okay. Have a great rest of your broadcast. I started that and I didn't know how to end it. You did the thing whenever, like, we joke about this, like when we don't know how to get out of something, we either sing it or we do a voice. Yeah, I turned into an old fisherman.
是的，好吧，我们身处这个世界。好的，格雷格。我们非常爱你。非常感谢你能来到这里。好吧。祝你接下来的广播顺利。我开了个头，却不知道该怎么收尾。你刚才又那样了，我们经常开玩笑说，当我们不知道怎么结束话题时，要么就唱出来，要么就用那种怪腔调说话。没错，我刚才变成了一位老渔夫。
You did. Thanks, Greg. Thank you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman, and the director of the audio
你做到了。谢谢，格雷格。谢谢。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗。我们的助理制片人是安斯利·布巴科。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼，以及音频总监
team is Sam Kiefer. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here.
团队是Sam Kiefer。我们这里有很多很棒的人。我们这里有很多很棒的人。我们这里有很多很棒的人。我们这里有很多很棒的人。我们这里有很多很棒的人。我们这里有很多很棒的人。我们这里有很多很棒的人。
We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. We have a lot of great people here. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis.
我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们这里有很多优秀的人才。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的助理制片人是安斯利·布巴科。Odyssey 的执行制片人是詹娜·韦斯-伯曼和利亚·里斯-丹尼斯。
Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Office Ladies由Chris Basil混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton创作的《Ruppertree》。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。